о.в.
[музика]
А це всеукраїнський форум Україна 30
освіта і наука Ми сьогодні продовжуємо
говорити
про цю сферу але більше занурилися в
тему науки досліджень винаходи і
безпосередньо їхньої апробації у
виробництві економіці Отож розпочинаємо
третій день всеукраїнського форуму
Україна 30 освіта і наука
знання це скарб
вміння вчитись ключ до нього
[музика]
змінюються
вона сприяє гнучкі що його і сучасні
цифровою і безбар'єрне наука все більше
цікавить молодці розробки і виходить
перетворюються на стартові а держава
підтримує і мотивує в і всеукраїнський
форум Україна 30 освіта і наука в
Ми
вітаємо усіх на всеукраїнському форумі
Україна 30 освіта і наука якщо попередні
дні ми говорили про дуже важливих багато
питань які стосуються і законодавчої
діяльності і міжнародної діяльності і
більш осучаснення і
цифровізації діджиталізації освітнього
процесу у цей день ми занурюємо
науки і ми будемо раді якщо справді наше
сесії дискусії сьогодні будуть для вас
дуже корисні пані та панове Вітайте на
цій сцені перший заступник голови
Верховної Ради України Руслан стефанчук
і
[музика]
у
Доброго дня Вибач Шановні колеги для
мене надзвичайно честь сьогодні бачити
справді еліту Еліт еліту української
освіти і науки ім О дуже приємно що
сьогодні нас зібрала тут надзвичайно
така непересічна І дуже важлива подія це
питання розвитку науки і освіти і що ми
можемо разом зробити для того щоб
Україна назавжди була і залишалася тією
а нацією інтелектуалів які знають що
робити своїм інтелектом і вміють його
застосовувати першу чергу Шановні колеги
я хотів би щоб всі ми згадали Імена
видатних українських вчених які завжди
створювали Пантеон української науки це
І ви шановні наші учені пакет у
Олександрович Богомолець і всесвітньо
відомий вчений Володимир Іванович
Вернадський і видатний вчений в галузі
медицини Іван Якович горбачевський і
видатний вчений фізик Олександр
генріхович гольдман і низка інших і
звичайно наша українська легенда яка на
превеликий жаль Минулого року о покинула
нас це грудьми Шановний наш академік
Борис Євгенович Патон із вашого дозволу
Я попросив би усіх присутніх тут згадати
всіх наших вчених які створили основу
для нашого подальшого розвитку як я
попрошу давайте згадаємо їх в
о.в.
у дякую прошу сідати
безперечно тут варто згадати що форум
який ми проводимо він проводиться під
егідою президента України Володимира
Зеленського і питання які до нього
виносься Мені видається вони повинні
бути максимально щиро про говоре Ні Тому
що тільки ми з вами можемо сформувати
той шлях той напрямок за яким повинна
рухатися українська наука і тому я дуже
прошу під час сьогоднішнього форму всіх
учасників бути максимально відвертими і
обговорювати всі ті питання які є
загальними для розвитку освіти і науки
крім цього я хотів би згадати ще одну
ініціативу яка була проголошена в перший
день Це питання створення
президентського університету Я вважаю що
це може стати надзвичайно такою потужним
поштовхом для розвитку і освіти і науки
в Україні тому теж на будуть дуже цікаві
і цінні вашої поради рекомендації задля
А як ви могли бачити які перспективи
цього проекту могли бачити всі основні
речі всі основні ідеї про які ми з вами
будемо говорити вони були включені до
проекту закону про цей президентські
університет Я також хотів би нагадати
всім вельмишановна присутнім що в 2021
році закінчується термін дії
встановлений законом України про
пріоритетні напрямки розвитку науки і
техніки і тому я знаю що зараз працює
еее група яка включає в себе
представників як влади так і
Міністерство освіти науки Національної
академії наук галузевих наук і тому для
нас дуже важливо справді визначте наші
перспективи в наукових дослідженнях на а
наступні 10 років Це ж саме стосується і
питань пов'язаних з інноваціями тому теж
Я хотів би щоб ми з вами обговорили
питання привітати напрямок напрямків
інноваційної діяльності в Україні і
переглянули їх з урахуванням
у тих загроз і викликів які
сьогодні пред'явлені суспільству
дуже багато питань сьогодні буде піднято
але мені здається що основним питанням
яким повинні говорити як ми бачимо
державну політику в сфері освіти і в
першу чергу а науки і мені видається що
ми можемо багато говорити але
концептуальний принцип він бо він
залишався незмінним в основі цієї
державної політики повинно стояти Його
величність вчений Тому що тільки цей
вчений як згусток інтелектуальну і
потенціалу може продукувати цій ідеї які
в подальшому можуть бути капіталізовані
і приносити ефект від його діяльності і
суспільству і державі і що важливо Ми
повинні зробити все щоб він сам був
заінтересований в цього в цьому я не
відкрию Америку якщо скажу що в у
справжнього вченого
найкраще що ми можемо зробити Клімкін
створення умов це не відволікати іншими
проблемами проблемою пошуку житла
проблеми й пошуку складних необхідних
для подальших досягнень по публікації
дороговартісний він повинен творити і
творити якісно і на благо нашої країни
крім цього я хотів би звернути увагу на
питання яке вже А давно вперед з'їло це
питання фінансування науки
Мені здається що якраз результатами
нашого обговорення повинні стати нові
підходи до того як ми бачимо разом з
вами фінансування науки я усвідомлюю що
еее наука Ви велика але чи а достатньо
Цей принцип невелику фінансування
розв'язування по все одно це всьому
спектру науки Що всякі дайте нам
потрібно виділити ті галузі науки на які
ми ставимо в першу у забезпечених
потужний фінансування для того щоб вони
продовжували бути локомотивами
української науки і битися безперечно із
забезпечення інших сфер Хоча я далекий
від думки що
еее Ми не можемо вирішити за рахунок
грантів і тому безперечно потужно
державна політика в цій сфері вона
повинна тільки зміцнюватися
окремо Я хотів би за питання
Академії Наук Національної академії наук
галузевих академій наук оскільки я маю
честь бути до долучених до а деяких з
них і мені видається що велика честь для
України що понад століття Ми маємо
можливість мати Пантеон кращих вчених на
яких ми повинні рівнятися і я о дуже
літаю оновлення яке відбулось
національній Академії Наук літає У пана
президента Національної академії наук
Анатолій Дуже приємно Мені здається що
зараз прийшов саме той час щоб за
результатами нашого обговорення ми
продемонстрували новий підхід і нову
якість до формування наукової діяльності
мені видається що тут
важливим етапом повинен стати проведений
вами і колегами внутрішню незалежний
аудит діяльності формування перспектива
на майбутнє і мені видається що якраз
і прийшов отой часу нам всім
докласти всіх зусиль
щоб Ми зрозуміли що основне в науці Це
її ефективність це є еее правильність
підходів щодо потенційної можливості
комерціалізація результатів які
твориться наука і мені видається що нам
потрібно все-таки запроваджувати отой
принцип Я знаю чому його вже частково
запроваджували який існує в цьому світі
Що якість науковця і якість наукової
установи не вирішується кубометра ми
списаних паперів він вирішується
кількістю патентів і кількістю
комерціалізація них речей які можуть
продукувати і говорити про якість тих чи
інших наукових
досліджень крім цього я хотів би дуже
проговорити з вами питання про те щоб
разом з фундаментальними дослідженнями
ми все-таки відводили велику увагу в на
сьогодні науці я наведу вам приклад
зокрема останнім часом спілкувалися з
представниками Національної академії
правових наук і ми вибудували отой
підхід за яким саме Національна академія
правових наук повинна стати головною
експертною установою при прийнятті
державних рішень Тому що тільки разом з
науковцями можемо говорити про те
наскільки правильно сформульовані ці
рішення наскільки вони ефективні і
наскільки вони якісні з точки зору їх
прийняття і тому я дуже би хотів щоб ми
разом пропрацювали це із іншими Академію
до до речі скажу вам отаку істину й
присутні тут президента Національної
академії галузевих не дадуть збрехати що
мою першу зустріч на посаді першого
заступника голови Верховної Ради України
я провів саме з президентом академії
галузевих наук і ми обговорювали ці
питання тому будемо вважати що це новий
етап оновлення цих відносин Я не
відмовляється від жодних ти принципи
якими з вами про ми працювали що наперед
вчений ефективність і те що приносить
користь суспільству
Також я хотів би
щоб разом з національною академією наук
ми працювали також систему прийняття
інших не тільки державно-правових Та
змістовних от рішень у всіх сферах
мається на увазі це і сфери економіки
сфері енергетики сфера гуманітарна тому
що саме важлива ваша думка тому що вона
складає фундамент і а держава повинна
тільки забезпечити ефективне рішення яке
буде уособлювати в основі те про що
говорить нам науковці велика або великий
такий
скажімо резонанс викликали деякі
намагання в у
політиків
запроваджувати різні тимчасові слідчі
комісії так далі я одразу от скажу Я
вважаю що це неправильно Я вважаю що це
не на часі Я вважаю що науковці повинні
творити і не створювати їм зайвих
проблем різними питаннями перевірками
якщо хтось один десь винен для цього
повинна працювати правоохоронну систему
А ми повинні зробити все Щоб повернути
повагу до науковця повагу до вченого і
тому я теж буду докладати до цих до
цього максимально зусиль
тепер хотів би поговорити декілька слів
якщо можна про ті проблеми як нам
залучити мови тому що я дуже багато
Зустрічай з молоддю і молодь Хоче чи не
хоче йти в науку і це зрозуміло це
питання житла це питання можливості
реалізації себе це питання
дороговартісний реактивів проведення
експериментів дослідної бази в А мені
видається що результатом нашої дискусії
також повинно стати ті механізми які ми
можемо запропонувати молоді в першу
чергу зацікавити її активного зробити
науку модною сучасною і можливою для
реалізації в Україні і тому я дуже прошу
щоб ми за результатами цього обговорення
також внесли свої пропозиції щодо
можливості забезпечення житлом молодих
вчених Я знаю що цього року виділено що
не помиляюсь 60 мільйонів гривень це
мало це нікчемного мало але давайте
думати Які ще механізми можемо
запровадити чи то само іпотечного
кредитування чи якісь інші для того щоб
молодь яка вийшла в науку не відчувала
себе обділений і хотіла Займатися цією
наукою і віддавати їй все своє життя
крім цього я хотів би
звернути вашу увагу на в до питання про
це говорив комерціалізації новацій мені
дуже тому що я паралельно що займаються
питаннями інтелектуальної власності дуже
важливо щоб ми в першу чергу почали
відноситись до інтелектуальної власності
як потужної складової національної
політики Тому що тільки переформатувати
все своє відношення і почавши серйозно
підходити до капіталізації
інтелектуальних вкладень Ми повинні
сформувати потужну інтелектуально
матеріальну основу університетів
науково-дослідних установ і держави
Україна і тому ми проводимо дуже багато
таких
інновацій ви знаєте що ми прийняли закон
яким створили національний офіс
інтелектуальної власності ми зараз
будемо переглядати патентне
законодавство зараз наразі питання
пов'язані з переглядом законодавства про
авторські й суміжні права 7 щоб ми
писали всі ці правильні правила які
створять закл у охорону першу чергу для
наших вчених щоб беручи участь в
наукових дослідженнях кожен вчений чітко
знав він буде мати з того не тільки
визнання бачення але і конкретний
матеріальний зміст що змусить його
відноситися З повагою до тих умов які
йому створені в Україні не шукати кращої
долі за її межами
Я дуже би хотів щоб ми проговорили цілий
як і інших питань зокрема пов'язані з
більшого наближення наукової діяльності
виробничої діяльності але думаєш такі
глибоко наукові теми які ви працюєте і
без мене але я от Хочу звернути вашу
увагу що вже 15 вересня уряд повинен
буде подати проект державного бюджету на
наступний рік і тому вважаю за необхідне
під час подання проекту бюджету 2012 рік
а працювати разом питання в ж стосується
і щодо оновлення та осучаснення
наукового обладнання
матеріально-технічної бази щодо
спрямування тих питань які пов'язані з
забезпеченням житлом молодих науковців
щодо питання збільшення фінансування
Національного фонду до досліджень і цілу
низку інших що вони колеги Я глибоко
переконаний що ми разом повинні зробити
все
щоб ми
ми реально сьогодні маємо шанс зробити
все щоб врешті-решт в нашій країні
словосполучення ти що дуже умний було як
визнання а не як порівняння тому я щиро
вірю інтелект я щиро вірю в науковців і
я щиро вірю в те що держава сьогодні
здатна зробити все для того щоб
повернути Престиж повагу і матеріального
забезпечення для науки дякую давайте
обговорюйте давайте спілкуватися давайте
разом зробимо все щоб було для науки
краще дякую за увагу Спасибі
Запрошуємо до слова президента
Національної академії наук України
Анатолія Загороднього в
[музика]
о.в.
у Доброго ранку
високоповажні пані і панове Шановні
колеги Дорогі друзі
Хочу подякувати ініціатором формула
запрошення взяти участь в його роботі
була для національної академії наук
України питання комунікації суспільством
і владою є надзвичайно важливим я хочу
подякувати користуючись нагодою першому
заступнику голови Верховної ради
Руслан стефанчук ку за добрі слова на
адресу Національної академії наук
України і національної галузевих
академій Наук України за конструктивні
поради і ті завдання які він бачить для
національної академії наук України а
також за ту підтримку яку ми
сподіваємося наша наука отримує від від
держави в
і прошу презентацію Ага
тепер коротко про те Чим живе І які
плани має Національна академія наук
України
хочу нагадати що наша академія наук
заснована в період визвольних змагань
українського народу у листопаді 1918
року
і плідність ідеї одного з її засновників
і першого президента вченого зі світовим
ім'ям Володимира Вернадського щодо
основних засад розбудови в Україні
власної Академії Наук доведена часом за
сторіччя своєї діяльності академія
пройшла шлях від декількох установками
такі ви комісії в яких працювали лише
140 співробітників до розвиненої мережі
науково-дослідних інститутів широким
фронтом фундаментальних і прикладних
досліджень в
Я хотів би зазначити що впродовж усієї
історії академії пріоритетним у
діяльності посідало вирішення
найгостріших проблем що постали перед
державою і суспільством і вчені робили
все можливе аби незалежна Україна
відбулася докладали значних зусиль для
розвитку її економіки освіти та культури
і зараз попри непрості умови наша наші
науковці продовжують активно і
наполегливо працювати отримуючи на
багатьох сучасних напрямів науки
результати дійсно високого світового
рівня про деякі з них вже згадували
своєму виступі в перший день роботи
нашого форуму водночас розвиваючі
насамперед фундаментальні дослідження
інститути Академії
значні зусилля спрямовують на широке
практичне використання наукових
результатів чимало перспективних
розробок і конкурентно спроможних
технологій знаходять застосування в
космічній в
в
[музика]
енергетичних та інших галузях ефективно
співпрацює з такими великими темними
організація
державного підприємства Антонов інші
івченка прогрес зоря-машпроект
навіть енергоатом акціонерне товариство
турбоатом та інші можливо що Ці зв'язки
дають змогу важливо що Ці зв'язки дають
змогу активізувати прикладну тематику
забезпечити так домовитий і прив'язку до
конкретних потреб виробничої сфери ось
Лише кілька прикладів практичної користі
за результатами оцінювання нашими
вченими стану корпусів реакторів атомних
електростанцій на 10 від 10 до 20 років
від детерміноване виведення з
експлуатації
11/15 діючих енергоблоків
економічний ефект від продовження
терміну роботи лише одного блоку
становить близько півтора мільярда а
далі наші фахівці розробили технологію
налагодили виробництво машин Для
контактного стикового зварювання рейок
із високоміцної сталі сумарний ефект від
цієї розробки мільярди гривень здійснено
та трансфер сучасних адаптивних
технологій вирощування озимої пшениці
інноваційних сортів на площі близько
двох мільйонів гектар в останні роки
вагомим пріоритетом діяльності академії
в дослідження є дослідження для потреб
оборони і безпеки держави
о.в.
є
чимало розробив спрямована на покращення
технічних характеристик зброї
боєприпасів ракетних та артилерійських
систем збільшення рівня балістичного
захисту підвищення живучості елементів
конструкцій техніки зокрема наші
науковці запропонували нові корпуси
лексика осколкових снарядів які
відповідають стандартним на там є одними
кращим з кращих світі де військової
медицини створено зокрема для матеріали
в
з біо матеріали
А
где матеріали для відновлення кісткової
тканини сучасна технологія
кріоконсервування клітин крові
різноманітні гемостатичні засоби та
спеціальні спеціальні пов'язки для
лікування складних опіків і ран усе це
без перебільшення життєво важливі речі в
а наші Вчені не залишилося осторонь
боротьби з пандемії карна вірусної
інфекції вони розробили надійні
перевертає я системи для діагностики
особливо небезпечних вірусних інфекцій
царська від вата інших вірусів включно з
комбінованою тест-системи за діями
моніторингу появи нових штамів
коронавіруси в Україні йде пошук нових
лікарських препаратів протягом він 19
створюється вітчизняні вакцини проти
нової коронавірусна інфекція
досліджуються причини виникнення різних
когнітивних порушень і триває Пошук
шляхів їх лікування щотижня готується
прогноз розвитку пандемії на території
нашої країни
ми Шановні колеги добре зрозуміла що
академії потрібно
змінюватись відповідно до вимог часу і
зміни вже почалися
Нам вдалося посилити демократичні засади
економічного устрою запровадити сучасну
методику оцінювання ефективності
діяльності наукових установ і навіть
принципи фінансування пріоритетних
наукових досліджень вдосконалити
структуру управління академії Зараз ми
розпочали повної інвентаризації
матеріально технічної бази та земельних
ділянок новий етап оптимізації мережі
наукових установ важлива увага в
програмі реформування академії
приділяється розвитку наших міжнародних
зв'язків подальша інтеграція до
Європейського дослідницького простору
серед наших пріоритетів залишається
якісна співпраці зі сферою освіти від
залучення школярів до наукової
діяльності в рамках малої Академії Наук
до підготовки магістрів і наукових
кадрів вищої кваліфікації на базі
наукових установ Національної академії
наук України ми постійно в центрі нашої
уваги перебувають вкрай гострі питання
залучення і закріплення в академії
талановитих молодих науковців ми чудово
розуміємо що це питання наше майбутнє і
намагаємося всіма доступними засобами
утримати мов своїх лавах запроваджувати
різні форми адресної підтримки молодих
дослідників
А для цього має нещодавно започаткували
гранти молодіжних дослідницькими
лабораторіями група програми
досліджень вперше в Україні намагаємося
створювати
для молоді умови для кар'єрного
зростання вживаємо заходів щодо
виділення їм службового житла проте наші
власні заходи нездатність сприймати
подальшого кадрового знекровлення нашої
наукової сфери розв'язувати цю проблему
треба на найвищому державному рівні про
що вже власне і сказав Руслану цілий
стефанчук Шановні колеги безумовно зараз
академія яким вся Вітчизняна наука
працюють у непростих умовах причинами
цього є недостатнє фінансування наукових
досліджень низький попит на наукові
розробки звуку промисловості падіння в
суспільстві наукової праці і пов'язаний
з цим відтік наукових кадрів але попри
всі негаразди українська держава ще не
втратила шансів на інновації у розвиток
і майбутнє процвітання Для цього на мій
погляд зусилля науки і держави повинні
об'єднатися
створення за рахунок
талановитих науковців Які створюють
інноваційної продукції
у Дякую за увагу
Дякуємо в
У пані та панове ми зовсім скоро вже
розпочнемо перші дискусії обговорення і
перша тема Цього дня форуму Україна 30
освіта й наука стосуватиметься сучасного
університету як майданчика для
дослідження процес за кілька хвилин вже
на основній сцені форму України
у своїх Головах вигравало Україна
розумієте Тому це можуть бути і не
тільки цієї підготовчі курси це можуть
бути і питання ви знаєте моє прийняли
про питання певного пільгового вступу до
українських вузів тому що це нас
привітати дехто каже що якісь ущемлення
українців і так далі Я думаю це не та
неправильно тому що ми всі українці і
тому ми всі повинні враховуючи умови в
яких ми живемо в яких ми знаходимося
створити рівні умови по доступності Але
все-таки мати якісь преференції для тих
людей які зараз перебувають очі
життям в якому не знаходяться ви знаєте
я оце на нещодавно був з
віце-спікера парламенту Польщі і
Литви далі на лінії розмежування і ви
просто реального це мали можливість
спостерігати ці умови в яких проживають
людина бачить території нам розповідали
що робиться на цій території Ми повинні
року а робити все що у вигравати
гуманітарну
якістю і умов які ми можемо
запропонувати Я вважаю що це непомірне
позитивного
на підконтрольну територію отримує
максимальну підтримку отримували А
максимальне сприяння Я думаю що дуже
багато залежить від трьох до людини
знаєте свого часу еее один з таких до
духовних лідерів України він сказав дуже
гарно фразу у на у нас існує брак любові
ми замінимо цей брак любові на гарне
відношення один до одного Я дуже багато
що щось зміниться Тому треба починати от
Кожен повинен починати себе як перед
Руслан Олексійович на формі
Ми зараз перебуваємо в Експо зоні
всеукраїнського форуму Україна 30 освіта
і наука і звісно спілкуємося із
представниками
Національної академії наук України і
вищих навчальних закладів які тут є із
різними ініціативами хакатона ми Я думаю
сьогодні також буде цікаво як і
попередні дні А це національний
університет біоресурсів і
природокористування України розкажіть
коротко по оператор покаже вашу ж
експозицію що тут представлена Чим ви
Найбільше пишаєтеся я не експозиція при
наданні експозиції представлено робот
маніпулятор Цей робот аналог в основу
моделі для автоматизації процесу на
виробництві
система керування даного роботу
для розвитку і
впровадження даних машин
потрібна певний час і
керування оптимальний рух
даність наші студенти університету
вивчають це еее сучасності потрібно
актуально
еее
пристрої призначені для моделювання
розробки 3D моделей об'ємної форми
добре
університету студенти молоді науковці
вчені мають свої розробки досягнення
вони мають змогу змоделювати розроб у
свій сучасний
візуалізувати власне те що вони задумали
А що це за Пеньок у вас тут це зразок
деревини що це
сканер для сканування даного зразка
використовується у 3D сканер так для
визначення об'єму деревини в лісі в
Лісових насадженнях для визначення
пошкоджень
деревини мають син увазі Ну а як це в
реальній застосовується в реальній
ситуації
в Лісових насадженнях нутрікс так есть
використовуйте радять сканування
наприклад на квадрокоптерах як визначити
об'єм деревини в певній зоні наприклад
на великій відстані на великій висоті
для цього використовують дані
пристрої а для моделювання самого
процесу
що минуту Оце так так до 3D сканер для
сканування еее
у зразків деревини
добре зрозуміло тут вас багато різної
техніки і експозиції А що то вас за і
ДАІ дивно що техніки що залишилося про
що вона зараз чи є певний робот
маніпулятора Ану ану давай роботи цей
Дана машина призначена для
обробки
систем керування рухом
наші розробки розробляється Канта
практично застосовується На даному
робить їх можна використовувати
налаштування параметрів реальних машинах
великих певних провідних компаній для
зернових складів для зернових
навантажувачів системи керування даного
роботу Можна використовують у Великій
машині в лабораторних умовах
[музика]
археологічні розкопки та ревас які
органи
спеціалісту Так
це у нас унікальна технологія
полімерного бальзамування якою володіє
лише минав в Україну на нашому група
представлена ці лабораторії по світу їх
взагалі є понад 500 в Україні виключно в
НУБіП України полягає процес в тому що
ми беремо біологічний об'єкт і замінюємо
рідини в ньому на полімери Таким чином у
нас з'являється
новий препарат який вже стає вічним
фактично чого він не піддається
біологічним пошкодженням для навчального
процесу навчальна просто так щоб
готувати майбутніх лікарів Наприклад
якщо
подивитися на такі зліз з коня
І тут якраз на ньому можна побачити всі
кістки всі зв'язки що є Скажем так
важливим під час підготовки майбутніх
лікарів
чудове Дякуємо носу до нас дуже цікаво
спілкуватися зі студентами із нашими
науковцями А ми зовсім скоро
повертаємося до основної зали де
розпочнеться перша сесія Цього дня в
а в Україні з'явиться університет який
готуватиме фахівців з кібербезпеки
ініціатива належить президенту
Володимира Зеленського
планується що до університету
відбиратимуть найліпших вступників які
отримуватимуть
стипендію у новому університеті будуть
сучасні лабораторії і біохімічні центри
студенти відразу матимуть і теорію і
практику також очікується Що в
університеті працюватимуть найліпше
викладачі як українські так і запрошені
іноземці а
[музика]
А які працюють в сфері центр
політико-правових реформ опору
напишіть такий закон яким би ви могли
пишатися
Потім ми вже проводили дискусії
практичні питання Я вважаю що правильний
підхід дуже багато інтелектуальних людей
ми повинні просто створити їм умови але
краще умови Це трошки підтримки і не
заважай
Верховна Рада збирається з реакцією на
проголошеного президентом Я думаю я знаю
що ця постанова зареєстрована
Мені здається станом на цей тиждень вона
а не стоїть але все може змінитися тому
що справа в тому що відповідно до
регламенту Верховної ради порядок денний
погоджується на еее погоджувальній раді
але ніхто не заважає це питання окремо
внести до порядку денного Я думаю що як
тільки буде
досягнутий компроміс цього питання
домовлялися одразу Верховній Раді Дяк у
надійшов сигнал що треба випускати
Верховну Раду Дуже дякую дуже приємно
щотижня це місце ставатиме майданчиком
для головних тем України серія
масштабних щотижневих ворогів України до
річниці державної Незалежності і А це у
великий діалог за участі влади
громадськості міжнародних партнерів
українських експертів
в дії комп'ютерне хабаря форум Це пошук
стратегії і тактики величезний поштовх
економіки і будівництва в Україні
стратегія
підвищення якості й ефективності чинного
законодавства Україна і відкрито
говорить і шукає рішення збирає
найкращий світовий досвід економічні
зв'язки між Україною та Литвою
визнавати міжнародно визнані кордони
Європейський союз України як і був
завжди під час форуму Влада спілкується
журналістам представник беруть коментарі
успіх також відбуваються спеціальність
а буквально доторкнутися до теми можна
в.в.
[музика]
у цій форми можуть дати вам розуміння
багатьох процесів
корисну інформацію та відповіді дуже
важливі хвилюючі запитання
форум України це відкрита розмова на
найважливіші теми житті країни що є
опорами нашої Незалежності в
у університет це не тільки місце
навчання це має бути і центр
дослідницької роботи Як усе це
реалізовуватиметься ми дізнаємося далі
тому я передаю мікрофон модерато цієї
дискусії олені паранюк докторант
національного університету біоресурсів і
природокористування України
введена генна терапія
отримає термоядерний плазму вже майже
дві хвилини Неможливо уявити розвинену
країну без активної добре профінансовано
і Наукової галузі а наукову галузь без
системи безперервної освіти навчати
інших навчатися самим створювати
опановувати фронтери знань ось ми та
сучасних університетів і тільки
забезпечуючи освітян можливістю і
стимулом включатися у дослідження що
ведуть провідні світові наукові групи
підтримуючи і фінансують чи наукові ідеї
дослідників і викладачів університетах і
наукових інститутах Україна зможе у
забезпечити стабільний і гармонійний
розвиток наукової освітянської спільноти
саме На сьогоднішній сесії
сучасний університет як майданчик для
досліджень ми мати можливість послухати
думки професіоналів
найрізноманітніших регіонів нашої країни
з цього приводу Отже Дозвольте
представити учасників першої сесії
сьогоднішнього дискусії
Андрій Дмитренко заступник міністра
освіти та науки України з питань
європейської інтеграції
Дозвольте представити
голову підкомітету з питань вищої освіти
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти
науки та інновацій
пан Віталій Пасічник проректор з
наукової роботи національного технічного
університету України Київський
політехнічний інститут
Олександр кордюк академік нан україни
директор Київського академічного
університету в а Володимир смоланка
ректор Ужгородського національного
університету президент Української
асоціації нейрохірургів
Отже Дозвольте надати слово і Вітренко
заступника міністра освіти та науки
України Про
Доброго дня шановні друзі Доброго дня
шановні колеги знаєте коли сюди їхав Я
подумав почав моделювати свої виступ і
згадав про те що
Минулого разу я бачу Минулого дня та
позаминулого дня що всі сидять але ж
знаєте чудово що я університетські
викладачі я скоріше за все буду
виступати перед вами стоїть глибокою
повагою до вас того що я так давайте
кафедру
відповідно до чинного законодавства це є
визначення які ви всі знаєте які
прописано в законі України Про вищу
освіту але неформально ми можемо його
визна А яким чином це місце де ми бачимо
синергію
поєднання таких речей як наукова в першу
чергу діяльність освітня діяльність та
інтернаціоналізація що робить сучасну
університет в житті кожного українця в
житті економіки України можемо бачити
чудово на слайді що робити університет
він відіграє фундаментальну роль у
формуванні через розвиток процесів
навчання та досліджень політики має
визначальне інноваційний потенціал
забезпечує розвиток
науково-педагогічного потенціалу Я хочу
сказати що сучасний університет це одна
з основних частин
інноваційної структури країни це місце
там де мають зароджуватися І це чудово
розуміємо в А все я керівництво держави
починаючи від президента України і
закінчуються міністром
міністром науки і освіти України Сергієм
а
у тому що робить керівництво держави
давайте згадаємо минулий рік 2020 рік
червень і Указ Президента України номер
220 про розвиток вищої освіти в Україні
на виконання цього указу Міністерство
освіти і науки розробила проект
стратегії вищої освіти в ньому при
розробці цієї стратегії брали участь
більше ста представників основних
стейкхолдерів нашої вищої освіти це були
представники Міністерства освіти і науки
народні депутати України представники
Національна академія наук Національна
академія педагогічних наук і багато
багато багато інших громадських
організацій та зацікавлених осіб
наступним кроком ми створили план
заходів щодо популяризації природничих
наук та математики адже популяризація
саме математичних і природничих наук є
основою для розвитку саме інженерних
спеціальностей саме вирощування тих
науковців які нам з вами у них не
вистачає про що сказав шановний
президент академік Національної академії
наук далі
інфраструктура всі чудово знають що
українських гуртожитків дуже часто не
вистачає багатьох що в деяких
університетах
але президент поставив чітке завдання
зробити нормальну університетські
інфраструктуру і зокрема побудувати нові
університетських гуртожитків на
виконання цього доручення нами була
створена та затвердження Кабміном
концепція державної програми
відновлення та розбудови мережі
гуртожитків для проживання студентів у
закладах вищої освіти на
2012-2020 роки
наступним інтернаціоналізація ви чудово
знаєте що велика кількість іноземних
громадян хочуть і мають навчатися в
Україні для цього ми робимо наступні
кроки І Перший з них завданням
президента була створена програма
популяризації освіти в а зокрема вища
освіта там величезна кількість
заходів Та ми маркетингові дослідження
особливим місцем займає електронна
платформа для навчання іноземних
громадян це між відомча електронна
платформа яка прибирає такі схеми як
посередники як обрання іноземного
громадянина Вона робить
прямий зв'язок між університетом та
іноземним громадянином вона буде робити
Так щоб сучасні українські університети
напряму спілкувалися з їх абітурієнтами
Окрім цього хочу нагадати що
робить багато і ви можете побачити
ініціативи для покращення в з системи
вищої освіти в Україні для того щоб
український університет розвивалося
особливо увагу Я хочу приділити еее
кредиту світового банку усі чудово
знаєте що в останні часи було багато
спекуляцій
незрозумілих думок щодо цього кредиту Я
хочу всіх розвінчати як сказав Пан
Руслан стефанчук Давайте говорити
відверто відвернув кредит спрямований
лише на розвиток системи вищої освіти
України за кошти цього кредиту будуть
розвиватися цифрова інфраструктура
університеті будуть розвиватися кадри
університетські будуть проведення
окремих навчання для вищої та середньої
ланки управлінців університеті буде
створюватись особливо інфраструктура
університету отримують найсучасніше
обладнання і все це для того щоб система
української освіти і науки розвивалося в
є основним принципом цього кредиту є
сильні стають сильнішими
мають об'єднуватися адже велика
кількість Україні має незначну кількість
студентів а успішними вони будуть лише
тоді коли вони об'єднують свої зусилля
задля покращення якості освіти в них
Дякую шановні друзі Хотів би Дякую за
вашу увагу якщо буде запитання
задоволення на них відповідь Дякую Дякую
пане в
А чия запитання у залі чи можливо є це
питання в наших учасників до пана Андрія
ні ні дякую тоді будь ласка надамо слова
пані Юлії
голові підкомітету з питань вищої освіти
комітету Верховної Ради України з питань
освіти науки та інновацій будь ласка
дякую дякую тебе теж вітаю всіх
учасників третього дня вже освітнього
форуму і хочу сказати що це чудово що в
нас з вами
еее з'являються такі майданчики де ми
можемо разом абсолютно відверто сьогодні
вже декілька разів говорили про це
спокійно
обговорити ті проблеми які в нас є в
освіті науці і головне обговорити шляхи
вирішення цих проблем для того щоб ми
всі свами разом рухались вперед нашого
світу і нашу науку Сьогодні такий день
які присвячені безпосередньо питанням
науки звичайно важливість науки
переоцінити взагалі неможливо тому що
все те що нас оточує всі ті можливості
які там дарує в в
сучасний світ це все те що ми маємо саме
завдяки розвитку науки та інновацій і і
кожен день
трансформуватися назвами примушує
безпосередньо розвиток технології
розвиток науки ми сьогодні робимо акцент
на тематиці розвитку науки в закладах
вищої освіти
На жаль
або на щастя я не знаю мало часу тому що
дуже багато питань потрібна видворити я
Буду намагатися
обговорити саме ті моменти які вважають
найважливішими чого з вами поділитися
сьогодні по-перше давайте я пропоную
поговорити про те яким чином
фінансуються взагалі на сьогодні наука
Наукова діяльність безпосередньо в
закладах вищої освіти в
А
в нас є на сьогодні дві системи
фінансування перша це конкурс на
фінансування проектів і це саме та
система яка вже працює в нас багато
років всі хто має
дотичність До закладів вищої освіти вони
всі чудово знають цю систему і вона
побудована саме на тому що я конкурсу
ман є гранти національного фонду
досліджень на підставі яких певні
програми наукові отримують фінансування
в закладах вищої освіти і є друга більш
сучасна і нова система фінансування це
базове фінансування за результатами
наукової діяльності Я хочу сказати що це
нова система яка була закріплена
нормативно
в минулому році і цьому році нас
фактично пілотний проект Коли
проводиться експертиза роботи закладів
вищої освіти наукової роботи за останні
п'ять років що стосується і практичності
Наукової нове та інших параметрів і
заклади освіти будуть отримати базове
фінансування на науку безпосередньо
закладах вищої освіти ось Наша задача на
сьогодні оцінити проаналізувати
яка система фінансування дає найбільший
результат оскільки який нам з вами
результат потрібен всій країні Потрібен
один результат щоб наука була в нашій
країні не заради науки а заради
практичних результатів і заради розвитку
інновацій який реально будуть рухати а
нашу Україну вперед друга
другий такий важливий момент на який я
тоже хочу звернути вашу увагу це питання
ааа
науково-дослідницького інфраструктури
про це про важливість інфраструктури як
важливість найактуальніше аптека на
сьогодні стоїть на першому місці в
системі вищої освіти говорив президент
Володимир Зеленський інколи відкривав
освітній форум він теж відзначив що
взагалі еее розбудова інфраструктури на
сьогодні є є основним пріоритетом
влади і президента України і Верховна
рада це визначає своїм пріоритетом і
Міністерства освіти як виконавча влада і
дійсно що стосується розвитку науки
закладах вищої освіти Ми всі розуміємо
що
безпосередньо наукового обладнання
робити науку неможливо в закладах вищої
освіти тому на сьогодні еее ми всі
об'єднані тим що ми
виділяємо кошти безпосередньо на
розбудову мережі центрів колективного
користування
науковими технологіями те того щоб
надати реально може втратити кошти і
надати реальну можливість нашим
науковцям отримати ті осередки де вони
зможуть реально працювати і мати якісь
результати ми всі знаємо що на жаль за
ці роки дуже мало уваги приділялося
безпосереднього інфраструктурі
науково-дослідницької на сьогодні вона є
на жаль нас застарілою вона не
відповідає сучасним викликам На у і тому
не перевірте цей вже визначених за
кошти виділені державному бюджеті і
зараз шляхом того що Міністерство буде
визначати найкращі найбільш наукоємні
заклади вищої освіти Там будуть
розбудовувати ся ось центри колективного
користування куди зможуть приїжджати
науковці з різних куточків нашої країни
і там безпосередньо творити науку це
перше що ми вже робимо сьогодні
ще декілька слів щодо інтеграцію в
Європейський дослідницький простір не
буде на цьому зупинятися ми всі
розуміємо наскільки це важливо а що нам
це дає Це нам дає звичайно обмін опитом
досвідом Вибачте спільні проекти
спільні досягнення і хочу звернути увагу
на те що вже зроблено які чим ми вже
можемо пишатися в Україні а
а а в нас є безпосередньо
співробітництво найбільш успішне по
трьох напрямах 1 це те що в нас на
сьогодні вже є угода між Україною і
Європейським Союзом про наукове та
технологічне співробітництво Це рамкова
угода яка не визначає якихось конкретних
дій але вона є вона є ратифіковано І
вона
політично закріплює співпрацю спільну
роботу і це є теж дуже серйозним кроком
вперед друге ви всі мабуть хто дотичні
до науки в нашій країні знаєте про ааа
такий проект
таку програму як горизонт Європа ми
працювали в цій програмі горизонт 2020 Я
хочу поділитися з вами еее досягненнями
які ми маємо тому що про це потрібно
говорити взагалі не програма горизонт 20
це найбільша програма в Європейському
Союзі яка спрямована на фінансування
наукових досліджень із з реальним
бюджетом майже 100 мільярдів євро
розуміємо об'єми цієї програми і хоче
сказати що
[музика]
Україна була асоційованим членом
безпосередньо в цій програмі ми дуже
активно брали участь наші науковці
активно брали участь ми посіли сьоме
місце серед всіх країн які брали участь
всі програмі і еее саме безпосередньо по
залученню коштів і хочу вам сказати що
станом на травень 21 року тобто фактично
станом на сьогоднішній день ми маємо
220г угод А які підписані безпосередня
нашими українцями українськими
науковцями нас на загальну суму 44
мільйони євро і я впевнена що майже в
кожного з вас є певні знайомі науковці
які працюють отримала грант у Гранд і
працюють роблять творять науку
безпосередньо а в рамках програми
горизонт двадцять двадцять Тому це вже
те що працює на сьогодні А це можна
пишатися і остання що буквально скажу
одну тезу наші теж дуже є такий успішний
проект це програма євратом
Atom так само наші науковці особливо
фізики беруть активну участь і показують
результати отримують фінансування
колеги це що стосується безпосередньо
науки заданих вищої освіти нас є
звичайна ще багато проблем ми їх знаємо
ми над ними працюємо нам потрібно
звичайна підвищувати заробітні плати
науковцям еее ми над цим працюємо і
знайте що освітянам підняли заробітні
плати в ну загалом це буде в нас така
програма 30 до кінця року заражена 10
відсотків підняли наступним нас будуть
обов'язкова науковців оскільки розвиток
науки є пріоритетом влади в нашій країні
і дещо декілька слів як народний депутат
Я хотіла вам сказати Що останнім ча а а
було прийнято парламентом або Нащо Ми
зараз звертаємо увагу в парламенті
безпосередньо коли ми говоримо про науку
Я думаю що більшість з вас знає про те
що було прийнято нещодавна закон яким
було впорядковано систему захисту
кандидатських і докторських дисертацій в
країні ви вже знаєте що нас тривав
декілька років експеримент по під'їзді
дисертаціями це експеримент закінчився
ми врахували всі недоліки і позитивні
моменти цього експерименту І що на
сьогодні було в цьому заході він вже
працює його президент підписав приблизно
місяць тому основні моменти нововведення
які запропоновані в цьому законі перше
це те що
тепер не врегульовано повноцінно захист
дисертацій і
експерти в разові
у спецради будуть підбиратися не за
спеціальністю то не за широким спектром
наукових інтересів а безпосередньо за
тематикою дисертації Яка буде захищатися
також
передбачення передбачена ціла система
норм яка запроваджує вже
електронний документообіг в питаннях
організації захистів це значно спростить
роботу закладів вищої освіти в
підготовці спец А головне наших
аспірантів
система стане прозорою всі ми будемо з
вами бачити перед захистом Хто є
рецензентом Хто є опонентом і звичайно
захист буде проходити
обов'язково в прямому ефірі це теж
важливо забезпечення принципу прозорості
так ще потрібно сказати що підсилили
принцип автономії закладів вищої освіти
і на сьогодні заклади А ти вже не будуть
просити дозволу на проведення захисту
Міністерства освіти А будуть повідомляти
Міністерство освіти про те що буде
відбуватися певний захист і надсилати
документи і держава за собою залишає
тільки функцію в
і контролю протягом 30 днів за тим щоб
ці документи відповідали
скажемо так всім встановленим
законодавством вимогам якщо будуть якісь
недопрацювання призупиняється строк
виправляються потім впливають та
Міністерство не зможе відміняти тепер а
захист Я просто буде коригувати
Скажімо так правомірність
Міністерства Можливо там не дуже це
подобається дандере центрі але ми
підсилює заклади освіти але окремо кожен
знати що і підсилюються і
відповідальність тому що і
відповідальність Вони тепер буде захист
нести самостійно оскільки Міністерство
не буде бо більше підтверджувати захисти
під'їзді дисертації Міністерство
атестаційна колегія продовжить
підтверджувати
захисти докторських дисертацій але тут
дисертації будуть закінчуватися захисти
безпосередньо атестацію закладу вищої
освіти і ви можете запитати одразу так
що це означає що взагалі не буде і
ніякого контролю за захистом дисертації
Звичайно він буде нас працює назяво
національна агенція з якості вищої
освіти до якої можна буде звертатися у
тих випадках коли будуть
можна говорити Що наприклад є випадки
порушення академічної доброчесності або
порушення порядку тепер переходимо до
академічної доброчесності декілька слів
ви всі знаєте що на сьогодні є в країні
великі проблеми з цим питанням нас є
законодавство яке визначає що таке
Академічна доброчесність що таке
академічний плагіат фабрикація
фальсифікація норми є але норми не
працюють тому на сьогодні я ось є
керівником робочої групи Андрій
Олександрович теж входить є членом цієї
робочої групи ми напрацювали вже на
фінальному етапі в нас цілий спеціальний
закон щодо питань академічної
доброчесності теж багато говорити не
буду це закон який вводить
безпосередньому ну У новий комплекс
взагалі відносин які пов'язані з
академічного доброчесністю нашій країні
починаючи від дитячих садочків шкіл
закладів вищої освіти Ми говоримо про те
що буде підсилювати ся принцип автономії
закладів вищої освіти але і
відповідальність буде підвищуватися тому
що тепер заклади вищої освіти будуть
відповідальними за створення всередині
системи забезпечення академічної
доброчесності і не толерантності до
порушення академічної доброчесності і
так само буде контролюватися питання
того щоб не було бездіяльності закладів
вищої освіти щодо безпосередньо
академічної доброчесності
так багато ще хочу вам сказати вже буду
закінчувати А зараз від'їжджає нас
парламентські де я буду їхати до
парламентської зали для того щоб
сьогодні ми будемо
комітетом відстоювати представляти у
Верховній Раді наш закон про підвищення
якості навчальної літератури і там а й
вперше на рівні закону введення норми
щодо
вимоги щодо відсутності
порушення нічного доброчесності а в
наших навчальних
посібниках за якими навчаються діти в
школах і наші студенти і навіть дітки
дитячих садочках там цей закон вже
передбачає один із основних принципів це
відсутність порушення принципу
академічної доброчесності це фактично
Вибачте можливо перебрала світанні Так
але те що коротко я ось хотіла донести я
вам донесла і я вам дякую за увагу я
всім Бажаю Вам сьогодні цікавою
співпрацю вас такі цікаві спікери
сьогодні і впевнена що наша освіта і
наша наука буде рухатися тільки вперед
всім Бажаю здоров'я дуже дякуємо пані
Юлія нажаль і Юлія еее залишити для
участі в засіданні в парламенті тому
дуже дякуємо їй за те що менше взяла
участь сьогодні І я хочу передати слово
проректор з наукової роботи у
національного технічного університету
України Київський політехнічний інститут
в
я вітаю Шановні колеги
Дякую за можливість поділитися досвідом
створення і розвитку інноваційне
екосистеми Сікорський челендж прошу
включити презентацію в
а а
наша інноваційна яка система
вибудовується протягом 10 років
чому вона виникла в КПІ одно
1898 рік в Києві створюється технічний
університет і я не побоюся цього слова
на інноваційних засадах
два корпуси з лабораторіями навчальному
аудиторіями будинки для професури і за
корпусом завод
і перша половина дня студенти вчаться в
аудиторіях і лабораторіях
друга половина дня на заводі опановують
найсучасніші на той день технології в
а а реальна
державно-приватне партнерство
дошка з іменами меценатів які вкладали
гроші в розвиток і створення КПІ висить
в нас головному корпусі
а-а-а інноватори І дух новаторства
самого початку був закладений в КПІ
Сьогодні ми чуємо Ілон Маск илон Маск у
нас Сергій Корольов і
це На мою думку вищого рівня ніж Elon
Musk Я дуже поважаю один з них працював
в умовах жорсткого тоталітаризму і
досягла величезних успіхів це Сергій
Корольов Ігор Сікорський реалізував тебе
у
умовах ринкової економіки
сьогодні КПІ є
наступником потужних наукових шкіл які
створювали наші науковці а сьогодні
понад 25 тисяч студентів різного рівня
науковці занурені в освітній науковий та
інноваційний процес і генерують щороку
приблизно 130 стартапів
у нас освітній процес побудований на
поєднанні
навчання
досліджень інновацій причому частинка
інновацій в освітніх програмах падає
приблизно 30
у наше інноваційна екосистема на
сьогоднішній день вже вийшла на
національний рівень і вона охоплює як
ядро Наш університет
місцеві місцеву Владу і закордонні
закордонних партнерів науковий парк
астарта школи і все спрямована на
створення інновації створення Startup
компаній
у На вході
навчитися і новаторство цьому треба
вчитися
можуть починаючи від школярів шкіл і
закінчується професорами університетів
вони всі можуть Пройти навчання в
старшій школі вони можуть представити
свої проекти на фестиваль інноваційних
проектів Сікорський челендж він є
щорічним і
працювати на створення власної Startup
компанія в
а-а-а ми останнім часом розвиваємо і
сприяє створенню інноваційних кластерів
міст і регіонів причому бачимо що серцем
і основою такого інноваційного кластера
повинні стати університети які є в
різних регіонах і там є велика кількість
людей зацікавлені в тому щоб реалізувати
себе в
у географія сьогодні виглядає таким
чином що це 14 регіонах України 18
закладів освіти залучені до цієї
всеукраїнської Націй на екосистеми тут
наведені університети які вже створені і
функціонують
tomtop школи хоче сказати що навчання в
школах я безкоштовне за гроші донорів
а а ми маємо власну мережу закордонних
міжнародних партнерів і представництв
які дозволяють найбільш перспективні
цікаві ідеї повсюди жувати
розповсюджувати по світу
ми маємо партнерів які щороку
підтримують наш фестиваль і підтримують
наших стартапи Ми маємо
[музика]
також і певну динаміку хочу щоб ви
звернули увагу на перші два роки 12-13
дуже скромні результати а в
чотирнадцятому році ми спостерігаємо
сплеск я по кількості проектів таких по
їх якості це пов'язано з тим що саме в
чотирнадцятому році була створена
стартап школа тобто до цього Ну ми
збирали те що як кажуть є а потім почали
цьому навчати навчатися і сьогодні ми
маємо стабільні результати в а а на
сьогодні виокремилися шість основних
напрямків за якими ведеться відбір
проектів і їх підтримка в а також в
а частина проектів які представлялися на
фестивалях сьогодні вже виведення на
ринок
у особливе значення в розвитку нашої
інноваційної діяльності ми приділяємо
забезпеченню безпеки і оборони
2019році за нашою ініціативою провели
першу оборону панель з безпеки і оборони
на які на одному майданчику
зібралися Новатори і підприємствами
високотехнологічних галузей які
зацікавлені в тому щоб ці розробки
виводити на ринок
і такі розробки вже виводяться і
виробляються підприємствами
високотехнологічних галузі декілька
прикладів 14-му році
аспірант нашого університету
запропонував
сьогодні за підтримки нашого партнера
Меридіан
у цей безпілотні spectator поставлене на
озброєння збройних сил України
прикордонної служби України і вже
пройшов перше модифікацію
всього-навсього сім років Це дуже
короткий шлях для виведення на серійне
виготовлення цієї продукції
а-а-а розробка для військових
портативний засіб для очищення води сова
який дозволяє практично з будь-якою
калюжу отримати питну воду в
з окремим нашим досягненням яка також
народилася яке також народилася в межах
інноваційної екосистему Сікорський
челендж я супутниковоі космічна програма
КПІ
2014 році був виведений на орбіту наш 1
університетські наноси путник1
він досі на орбіті можна знайти на
спеціальний сайт і подивитися в режимі
реального часу де не знаходиться почав
проекту планувалося що він повинен
функціонувати десь два роки не більше і
вже 7 років успішно функціонує на орбіти
2017 році був запущений 2 наш на
супутник політ N2 Я хочу звернути вашу
увагу що якраз ці проекти зародилися за
підтримки фондів які були залучені до
фестиваль інноваційних проектів а
сьогодні вже держави підтримується
насування ще два наших Нано супутники
які плануються для виведення на орбіту а
найближчим часом
проект очищення води має безпосереднє і
важливе значення для безпеки нашої
держави
А якщо коротко про результати то
110 високотехнологічних компаній увійшли
до складу наукового парку
приблизно 150 високотехнологічних
продуктів і технологій передаються для
впровадження в Реальний сектор економіки
і що дуже важливо А що щороку а понад
3000 учасників залишаються ось коли цієї
інноваційної екосистеми понад 60
відсотків це не КПІ зараз проекти це
проекти які йдуть від інших
університетах і а звичайна Ми запрошуємо
учасників взяти участь у фестивалі
інноваційних проектів Сікорський челендж
Україна який відбудеться 12 по 14 серпня
в а-а-а і він присвячений також 30-ти
річчя незалежності України і наша мрія
щоб стати моделлю
високотехнологічної економіки України
сприяти підвищенню обороноздатності
нашої держави і Руслан стефанчук
закликав бути відвертим наші дискусії І
я хотів би повернутися до теми
президентського університету
реалізація цієї чудової потребує
вдумливого ставлення і законодавчого
забезпечення
хотів би звернути увагу на такий аспект
який мені не дуже подобається там
закладена норма що випускник
університету повинен відпрацювати в
державному секторі в а а давайте
покладемо на одну чашу терезів
інноватора який може створити Startup
компанію і при мусимо його відпрацювати
чотири роки в державному секторі чи піде
Ілон Маск умовний працювати в державний
сектор А якщо піде де він буде
ефективніше питання дискусійне але це
воно потребує А вдумливо такого
ставлення я щиро дякую за увагу Ну і
мрії збуваються Дякую Дякуємо пане
Віталію на вашу доповідь
запрошую до слова Олександра кордюк а
ректора Київського академічного
університету України Академіка нан
україни в
у цій сесії мені дуже сподобався виступ
Руслан стефанчук А можна підписатися під
всім тим що він і справді це я вважаю
дуже добре А що
керівництво держави починає піарити
науку і це дуже класно а що стосується
проекту президентського університету то
а також я вважаю що це
стосовно піару науки і
дуже дуже гарно Ну правильно Мені
здається виписані напрями напрями
розвитку відповідно Які Ті теми які
будуть підтримувати університет хоча
скажімо якщо по результатам першого дня
Та я дещо розчарований власне в з
викладенням викладенням викладенням
концепції тому що як на мене на фізика
експериментатора надто багато загальних
слів слова слова правильні Але вони
надто загальні і у даному випадку я
якось переконаний що ці скажімо якщо
взяти взяти там caltech і перенести його
в Україні Україну Там зі своїми зі
своїми будівлями вирвати його
силіконової долини з викладачами і
студентами він там протримається там не
більше ніж кілька років зрозуміло що
треба формувати оцю структуру структуру
структуру взагалі а зв'язки
потрібно щоб у держави виникала
необхідність у економіки виникали
необхідністю наукових результатах і у
цих студентах і відповідно
а власне хотів справді розказати про
Київського академічного університету як
такий приклад а не власне того торта
також можна сказати дослідницького
університету який ми
розвиваємо тут власне посилання на сайт
це можна подивитися те що я не встигну
сказати
поки не працює Треба направляти
а а Вибачте добре
відповідно Київська Академічна
насправді державна Наукова установа
повна назва і основний принцип який ми
сюди закладаємо це Learning by
International
українського краще краще перекладати як
це навчання через дослідження й
світового рівня тому що тому що
дослідження справді дослідження
міжнародні вони світового рівня вони не
можуть не бути міжнародним
дослідницький університет а як взагалі
основні риси як ми бачимо як я бачу
дослідницького університету він має має
вирішувати такі дві
готувати студентів в
тренувати вирішувати такі дві основні
сходинки можна сказати за перше це вчити
вирішувати задачі і друге що дуже
важливо цей задачі ставити А і В
о.в.
у погано переключаються знову ж таки не
може звідки звідки взагалі береться
якась впевнені що ми знаємо що робити
Так і я хочу відповідно трошки трошки
про історію що таке Київський
академічний університет а це
власне він був реформований і
сформований якийсь університет можна
сказати тільки у 19-му році й я почну з
кінця що значить він зараз створений як
установа спільного підпорядкування
Національної академії наук і
Міністерство освіти і науки а і тут
важливо якщо починати з міністерства чим
цікаві як мені здається Міністерства
тому що це такий маленький проект і це
пілотний проект А якісь ідеї оцій ідеї
Як їх можна розвивати і що треба робити
це легше перевіряти на маленькому
проекті з іншого боку У нас є і великий
досвід і ми виникла не на порожньому
місці а реформували так званого
Київського відділення
Московський фізико-технічний інститут
свого часу я там навчався саме у
Київському відділенні і це власне у
Союзі був такий дослідницький
університет власне який вдалося
реалізувати недивлячись нінащо III
відділення Це була геніальна цей
університет інститут тоді називався він
от саме був направлений на підготовку
практичних практичних навичок вміння
вирішувати задачі і збирали
найкращих студентів з усього Союзу тому
числі з України й реальною
такого рішення а Бориса Євгеновича
Патона було створено київське відділення
яке відповідно забирала назад студентів
І власне власне академія вона авто
працювала у цей університет взагалі
працював як система дуальної освіти для
академії а і що важливо це залучення
студентів як якнайшвидше до наукових
досліджень і наукові дослідження Ну у
нас зараз власне власне що ми
маємо цього досвіду це за ці роки у нас
випущено більше тисячі випускників І цей
досвід Він дуже важливий тому що сказати
що навчання через дослідження це
зрозуміло Однак однак є багато нюансів
як це реалізувати і один з таких це маю
зрозуміла що треба долучати студентів до
живої науки жива наука це дає і
мотивацію
студентам це цікаво коли цікаво тоді
вони мотивовані і жива наука о хоча у
нас університет маленькі однак за нами
стоїть уся потужність Національної
академії наук це це можливість вибору
вибору студентами найкращих
у лабораторії найкращих
найкращих науковців І власне важливою
важливою це є індикатором також звісно є
необхідність це є розвиток сталого
міжнародного співробітництва Отже якщо
трошки підсумувати то я вважаю що
дослідницька навчання може бути
реалізовано тільки через живі
дослідження а для того щоб реалізувати
вже від дослідження відповідно до треба
активно залучати саме активних науковців
певних лідерів напрямків e-auto нашому
університеті всі науковці сумісники так
само як і було і я пам'ятаю як студент
відчувалася коли людина вона займається
вона займається наукою однак
відволікається і викладає студентам
розповідає студентам як робити Ти
відчуваєш це жива справді жива наука і
це сильно мотивує далі далі відповідно
вся наукова робота у нас наукова робота
студентів вона Я у центрі на у кіно
процесу все взагалі студент У нас є у
центрі
такий підхід
індивідуальний підхід і для того щоб цю
живу науку справді мати То треба мати
стали міжнародне співробітництво і також
важлива інноваційна складова залишилося
буквально кілька слайдів а от ще на
цьому слайді це власне структура Я хотів
сказати отам минула доповідач А я власне
хотів А
прореагувати на
таку тезу як наука заради науки Що це
наче погано і наука заради заради
практики так Так
ми всі розуміємо що наука заради
практики вона сама по собі неможлива
практичне застосування що вона
грунтується на має усі ці усі ці
винаходи інновації вони з'являються не
часто вони з'являються випадково і вони
з'являються на гру ж вони з'являються на
грунті який який створює фундаментальна
наука й підтримка фундаментальної науки
дуже важлива і ми бачимо структуру
нашого
університету
підтримання двох напрямів по-перше це
розвиток фундаментальної науки значний і
для цього дуже важливо така циркуляція
через через міжнародні міжнародні
проекти через міжнародне співробітництво
з іншого боку тут ліворуч А це важливо
розглядати університет як систему
дуальної освіти для залучення наукоємних
компаній також нами підтримуються
буквально приклади які працюють з таких
проектів які вже працює чотири роки
українсько-німецький проект фінансується
переважно
німецьким міністерством освіти і науки
це було близько ми у на Євро на чотири
роки здебільшого на стажування цього ми
бачимо наскільки це гарно для студентів
і ми розуміємо взагалі
ця система працює наступним планується
очевидно створення Української
німецького центру досліджень а і
важливий от Анатолійович також згадував
проект академ академ Сіті академії
установ Академмістечка знову у
співробітництві з
німецькими колегами на прикладі такого А
такого наукового парку як Берліна ми
плануємо побудувати науковий парк тут і
важливих просто важливий елемент його
наукового парку це об'єднання трьох
важливих компонентів це відповідно
дослідження це інновації це студенти це
А який займається студентом і власне
університет коли я кажу про це маленькі
університет я не маю на увазі ми
розглядаємо як університет мене боремося
з іншими університетами за студентів А
ми розглядаємо це як такий місток між
університетами і академією має до всіх
наших проектів Ми залишаємо студентів з
інших університетів запросто і саме
метод не є конкурентами
власне все дякую за увагу я
передаю слово Володимир Володимир
основинці ректор Ужгородського
національного університету і президента
української асоціації нейрохірургів і я
вас попрошу трохи підшитись щоб ми
влізли в онлайн-трансляцію часові рамки
Добре дякую дякую за слово надане слово
Шановні колеги має коротка презентація
буде присвячена реалізації студентських
напрацювань в реальному секторі
економіки
А я хотів би почати з цього слайду який
демонструє
перелік тих компаній які в значній
степені змінили наше життя і власника
мабуть якщо ми говоримо про молоде
покоління людей то змінило або формує
навіть життя молодого покоління цей
Microsoft Google Facebook reddit
WordPress звичайно та структура яка була
створена на початку 20 століття але
функціонує і є надзвичайно впливовою до
сьогоднішнього дня
еее більшість людей навіть
сказав би так у світі знають прізвища
цих людей які створювали ці компанії це
еее це але все це блін
Сергій Брін і Пейдж
але тільки невелика частина і
у this проекти були створені ними цими
людьми які зараз є надзвичайно відомими
тоді коли вони були студентами і вони
створювали це в студентському середовищі
і ми бачимо що більшість проектів
створено якраз невеличкими групами
студентів які нерідко були просто
однокурсниками
і
ми розуміємо що від ідеї до втілення
ідеї проходить досить довгий час
тривалий час як спробував для себе
накидати як ідея реалізується
еее і втілюється в бізнес-середовищі до
цього потрібно мати допитливих студентів
хоча би групу невеличку групу студентів
які володіють знаннями
які
мають інформацію в
у і які мотивовані про що ми сьогодні
говорили і на основі цього вони можуть
вивчити потреби і ринку і сформувати
певну ідею чому коли ми говоримо про
ідею про ідеї молодих людей про
якісь ідеї тому як правило говоримо про
студентські ідеї ідеї студентів про
стартапи зокрема тому що саме в
університетах зосереджено створена
атмосфера коли молода людина приходячи
університет еее може захопитися і
отримати мотивацію спочатку морально
психологічну мотивацію для того щоб
займатися наукою у нас в університеті в
Ужгородському національному університеті
є принцип у хорошого студентами
виховуємо тільки тоді коли з першого дня
з першого курсу пробачають він починає
займатися науку тоді ми знаємо що з
нього вийде хороший фахівець Він має
можливість долучитися до науки і ми для
цього надаємо йому ресурси що дуже
важливо в цій схемі
це те що я відзначив що і ідея в
у на
її втілення мають мати наставника це
значить що
безпосереднім учасником зокрема стартапу
але наставник mentor він та людина яка
підказує яка може направити нашого
студента яка може підказати куди
рухатися далі звичайно потрібен ресурс а
хочу сказати що ресурси у більшості
крупних університетів є Я хочу сказати
що наприклад має в Ужгородському
національному університеті
впродовж останніх трьох років маємо
можливість купляти апаратуру саме для
проведення наукової роботи
Ну і
безумовно потрібен реалізатор ресурси не
тільки
матеріально-технічна база це також
інтелект це команда це фінанси про що я
буду говорити далі
ми знаємо що кожна
компанія невеличка Бо велика
підприємницького на проходить чотири
етапи свого розвитку і саме перехідний
період є найбільш складним і він має
вісім ключових принципів від визначення
напрямку діяльності та зосередження на
цілях до швидкої та коректної оцінки
ризиків та слабкостей цілий ряд типів
проектів наукові виробничі дуже
популярні на сьогоднішній день є
краудфандингові платформи коли
споживач покупець уже
інвестує не маючи ще продукти наперед в
виробництво яке Тільки буде
налагоджуватися дуже важливими для
реалізації цих різних студентських
проектів є національний грантові
програми в є дуже важливим і у нас
досить
є
співробітництво з місцевою владою і
навіть розроблена така програма
конкурентоспособности спроможності
Закарпатської області звідки миті
нанизуємо переможців зокрема наших
стартапів і
звичайно ресурси нашого університету Це
і створення наукового парку і startapp
я дуже швиденько покажу про результати
це тільки ті проекти які вже вийшли до
фіналу ви бачите почали в 16 році
оскільки всі 16 році була Startup
головна створена в кінці 16 року
науковий парк еее
о 19 проектів і ви бачите що десь біля
Це ті проекти які вийшли у фінал ми
бачимо маємо переможців яких також
Стараємося стимулювати кожен із
переможців отримує кошти і ми вкладаємо
більше ста тисяч гривень для того щоб
стимулювати наших переможців яких ви
бачите тут є
25/4 останніх проекти зовсім абсолютно
різноманітні адже має класичному
університетом і тому ви бачите від
медичних проектів до проектів які
використовуються в харчовій сфері від до
проектів які є
еее використовуються в різних галузях
економіки Для прикладу хоч що навести
перед закінченням декілька проектів це
зокрема система дистанційного
спостереження з елементами доповненої
реальності якого розроблена для
пропозиції для нашого МЧС яке
складається у модулі які в бачити й
деякі визначають параметри
життєдіяльності людини зокрема пожежника
можливо який працює в небезпечній зоні
центральний блок керування і вбудований
шолом
рятувальника третій модуль який дає
містить датчики трьох типів освітлення
температури тиску вологості
дистанційний термометр і ви відповідно
це все виводиться на вигляді віртуальної
реальності на окуляри або на на сам
шолом для того щоби той пожежник або
людина яка працює в небезпечній зоні
бачила всі
зовнішні і внутрішні параметри
відповідно могла діяти відповідно людина
яка керує цим яка є керівником цього
допустити групи яка працює в небезпечні
якійсь ділянці вона також може
контролювати
самопочуття почуття цього конкретного
конкретної людини рятівника зокрема але
це можна використовувати також у в
інших проектах і соціальних догляд за
старими людьми
літньої літнього віку за дітьми
неспроможними тд і
дуже швидко реалізувався Вже в п'ятьох
містах це Ужгороді у Львові у Києві
зараз планується в Дніпропетровську
Миколаєві
реалізувати це qrator це також з наш
проект наших студентів який дозволяє з
допомогою QR коду який з якого
зчитується інформація швидко замовляти
блюда і отримувати швидко
розраховуватися ви бачите що час
очікування на двадцять хвилин
скорочується за рахунок цього вони
зробили Обирай цьому році зробили і
проект
зв'язку з
повідомлю Дина або заходить на сайт де
такі кафе які реалізують які реалізували
вже цей проект ви бачите і
або підходячи до
А де звідки можна отримати їжу
вони зчитують
відповідно він поступає до
вибір блюд поступає до кухні і вони
виносять ти або підвозять те що потрібно
для того або іншого споживача хочу
сказати що ми підтримуємо ці проекти як
казали фінансово і ми наші бачити хлопці
три хлопця який розробили цей проекту не
були направлені в Швецію колмар місто
колмар і там виграли і там виграли перше
місце і були визнані переможцями Я дуже
цікавий проект який починаємо
реалізовувати це екологічні вибори
біоматеріалів рослинного походження це
вироблення посуду а також зубковичи
коробок з рослинних відходів він трошки
загальмувався зв'язку відомо але ми
зараз його почали знову стимулювати до
реалізації це лише невеличка частина
великої гами проект і існує в
Ужгородському національному університеті
але я впевнений в тому що за підтримку
останніх за підтримки університетського
середовища місцевої влади і держави
за наявності національних міжнародних
грантових програм студентські проекти
можуть успішно бути реалізовані в
реальному секторі економіки Дякую за
увагу
а зараз нас чекає ще невеличкі бонус
лауреат Нобелівської премії з економіки
у 2007 році член Національної академії
наук США записав для нас невеличке відео
звернення до українських науковців
освітян Отже будь ласка послухаємо о
e-ips
новою привілеї додати кілька слів до
цього призводить до ідеї установлення
президентського університету в Україні
люди дивилися на Київ для як на важливий
культурний центр уже більше 1000 років
традиції навчання і
тут глибокі але Дозвольте з вами
поговорити
суспільство навіть засадничі ідеї
соціальної теорії суспільної теорії це
дій як і коли ми розвиваємо спільні
проблеми
суспільство які здається дуже по-різному
організоване за час який ми пам'ятаємо
люди знати України
відчували
дуже
незвичайні зміни економічної та
політичної у тебе історію була нелегка
із зміною
але
історія
у вашій країні роблять потенційно
чудовою чудовим соціальним теоретиком
Юстя ви можете
скликатися на практичний досвід для того
щоби розвивати нові теоретичні розуміння
фундаментальних рис різниць між
комунізмом ми капіталізму між
температурою демократії тому я
передбачаю великі внески від того що вас
буде засновано академічного установу
люди досліджувати муть проблемною різних
суспільствах і коли ви будете Дякуємо
переймаєшся в
українській освіті і науці і я дякую
учасникам Керівництво університетів
представникам влади за те що ви взяли
участь у нашій дискусії дуже цікаві
Нажаль ми трохи перебрали час тому немає
нас питань часу на запитання Отже я хочу
ще раз подякувати вам і всім присутнім
за те що ми взяли взяли участь у
дискусії і Допобачення
ще раз Дякуємо усім учасникам Я
сподіваюся що як завжди в кулуарах
нашого форуму можна обмінятися думками і
знайти
корисну для себе теж однодумців зовсім
скоро буде наступна сесія про залучення
молоді до науки зокрема академічної
з першого Європі тому що видно там є
матеріально-технічна база але особисто в
мене є дуже позитивне ставлення до
України і налаштування працювати тут і
розвивати саме нашу українську науку
Звісно якщо є підтримка якщо
відчувається допомога То ці прагнення
будуть набагато більш продуктивними
Дякую дуже так і будь ласка коротеньке
Ремарка бо я маю вас відпускати вже
настане насправді хороший зріз для
статистики і описуючи наших школярів
старшокласників які займаються там
навчально-наукової діяльності в школі ми
констатуємо що вони не хочуть їхати
закордон відсоток дуже мізерний і тільки
стикаючись з реальністю ВУЗі а потім в
академічному середовищі ми підтримуємо
зв'язки з нашими випускниками ми бачимо
що чим далі тим більше вони
розчаровуються і розуміють що в них
немає виходу і в той же час комунікують
чистими хто працює за кордоном Вони
хотіли повернутися до України
А за певних умов дякую
Я хотів би
виступів доповідачів
чи буде повертатися будуть якщо якщо
будуть створені умови а вони будуть
створені я не знаю тому відповідь чи
будуть повертатися залежить від питання
чи буде створення умов і 2 ще дуже
важливо треба якесь відчуття
стабільність Наприклад якщо ви даєте
ґрант тим самим національних досліджень
на 2 роки 2 роки людина може получати
досить велику зарплату А що буде далі А
що буде далі невідомо тому я думаю що
найближчі 2-3 роки Нам не слід
розраховувати на те що нас буде дуже
велика скажемо так
новина повернення з-за кордону треба
більше орієнтуватися на власні сили наш
кадрів залучати школярів а через п'ять
років поспіль
на 30 і Ми продовжуємо знайомити вас з з
експозиціями локація ми які
представляють Українські науковці
зокрема далі про
Інститут фізики напівпровідників якій
перебуває в системі Національної
академії наук України нашу проте вже
дещо показав ви можете більше розповісти
про те що саме з нині інститут
представляє для відвідувачів нашого
форум учасників які тут
інституту фізики напівпровідників
представлений двома основними розробками
люди будь ласка в нас представлена
комбінована Вітрова і фотоелектрична
електростанція
називається вона електростанція саме
тому що тут під сонячними батареями
вмонтовані акумулятори і ця комбінована
система може працювати і вдень і вночі
тобто коли вдень в нас працює котел
електричний електростанція вночі в нас
працює вітрячок під заряджає і ви завжди
в польових умовах можете з ми вважати
свою апаратуру мобільні телефони
комп'ютери планшети тобто все що вам
потрібно там де немає струму добре яка
середня потужність іде це крім
спеціальних таких вимог якщо це справді
побутової користувачем там за Мандрівник
машині можете надані експозиції Ви
можете бачити два макети меншої
потужності 40вт і ось подалі більшої
точності
80ah тобто наше макети ще в 14-му році
ми 20 штук виготовили за власні кошти
передали в зону АТО тобто вони
використовувались і пройшли апробування
для побутового призначення це будь-які
туристичній галузі Коли ви їдете на
природу тобто завжди нехватає
електричної енергії тобто якщо ви хочете
побути в палаці самостійно там це коли
на кілька діб ми справді да-да-да а
попід зарядитись у дорозі Тобто ви
відпочиваєте робите свою справи на пляжі
будь ласка апаратура заряджає ваш
мобільний телефон і НАК розумію що
фотоелементи це теж нашого вона так да
це фотоелементи виробництва не забуду
квазар-мікро
ААА наша робота полягає в об'єднанні
цього всього і компонуванні самої
системи Загалом ми отримали патент на
винахід на цю систему і готові до
впровадження деякі Перемоги ми ведемо
але Дозвольте будь ласка еее
освітлювальний прилад освітлювальний
прилад Як ви бачите він потужний цей
прилад
мощностью
150 Вт
він може замінювати 10-20 звичайних
світлодіодних лампочок і призначений для
освітлення великих
на площі наприклад як на форумі декілька
таких приладів буде достатньо щоб
посвятити цю площу Ми думали про
зменшити кількість приладів Зверніть
будьласка увагу
більшої потужності
501 зможете два чи бачу
в ньому закладені Навіть ні
науково-технічні розробки в цьому
унікальність чому
унікальність цього освітлювального
приладу полягає саме в охолоджувальний
системі
зроблений цей радіатор
Кристал виготовляємо нами його закуповує
у партнерів Але для того щоб ну в одному
маленькому об'ємі зробити велику
потужність потрібна система охолодження
велика тобто і еее наша
науково-технічний унікальність саме в
розробці цього охолодженню пристрою який
з не дозволяти безперебійно працювати
І я ще хотів подякувати
можливість зробити цю наукову технічну
розробку національного фонду досліджень
України яка видала грант на розробку в
минулому році ми виграли його і зробили
еее роботі метод Добре я дозволю собі
повернутися із цікавості просто до ааа
фото електричних панелей так які
сонячної енергії вітряків оскільки вже
сказали про те що може бути різні
потужність цікавить інше якщо це навіть
дача і чи можна я розумію не може бути
стовідсотково автономним Ну тому що або
дуже хмарно буде або буде вітру До речі
от тобто є різними потужностями з
різними площами А якщо справді хмарно Ми
навіть бачимо
Скандинавські країни де б я більше
календарного року більше половини
календарного року це хмарні дні але
застосовується якщо
ми говоримо про день тобто коли в нас є
день тобто сонце навіть за умови хмар
просто потужності росіяни й Сонце менше
ви можете згадати коли в хмарний день
виходите на море позагоряти начебто
сонці не можна
тому
радіація від сонця Тобто вона проходить
через хмари і отвори меншої потужності
але принаймні це буде все звертає вашу
увагу що в даних сонячних панелях
вмонтовані акумулятори тому еее ну хмари
то є то немає
сонячна панель заряджає акумулятори А ви
вже безперебійно заряджає те свій
пристрій добре а з самою
установку як воно комбінують і це є
спеціальна програма тому що комп'ютер
автоматизують як розумію що включити щоб
виключити значить дивіться в панелі
стройной спеціальний електронний
пристрій
який регулює
еее зарядку акумуляторних батарей і він
сам бачить де більше потуги йде від
електростанції або від сонячної панелі і
переключає і коли досягнута максимальна
заряджений акумулятор вам нічого не
потрібно
заряджати він відключає від зарядки
тобто і система працює в холостому ході
дуже цікаво Дякую дякую дякую Я певен що
це лише невеличка частина Дещиця усього
того що справді на чим працюють наші
Українські науковці можливо справді як
було заявлено їх презентації президента
Національної академії наук України що
таке і проектний грантовий у підхід до
фінансування певних в він може допомогти
цікавим ініціативам які потім ще легко
застосовуються в реальному житті зовсім
скоро повернемось до основної сцени де
будемо говорити про молодих українських
науковців
інноватики та проектах для країни це
надзвичайно важливо тому що насправді
за досить невеликі кошти можна
отримувати гарні результати тому що
інноватор він не приходить до держави де
гроші він думає як тими ресурсами до
якого він має доступ а реалізувати
власну ідею створити бізнес звичайного
не треба допомогти йому треба навчити
йому треба дати можливість а якісь
отримати доступ до ресурсів отримати
експертизу своїх не хотів але це
потенціал для нашої країни надзвичайно
великий Але для того щоб ці ідеї не були
Ну скажімо так школярки минув гарному
розумінні цього слова а все ж таки вона
повинна грунтуватися на дослідженнях на
фундаментальних наприклад них і це місія
університетів а забезпечуючи реалізацію
ефективних досліджень ще і не забувати
про підтримку ті молоді і тих науковців
Які створюють Startup проекти аби
безумовно для нас дуже важливо увага
держави щодо ааа розвитку дослідницької
інфраструктури без якої якісні
дослідження неможливі Ми звичайно
увага
держави до матеріального забезпечення
науковців особливо молодих є запорукою
того що наша молодь буде науку інновації
творити тут в Україні Дякую у Дякую пане
Олександре
виходить що я можу погодитися з усіма
тому що насправді з одного боку З одного
боку дуже позитивно на мене те що
керівництво держави
починає артикулювати і значить
важливість науки і наукового наукової
освіти те що справді у нас
намічаються серйозні проблеми а з іншого
боку видно що є багато багато таких
кейсів які де На прикладі яких можна
вчитися і я дуже згодом що треба
дискутувати і обговорювати далеко не
тільки те що вдається А на сам
це всеукраїнський форум України 30
освіта і наука як в науку зокрема
академічну науку залучити молодь
зацікавити молодь про все поговорити
експерти які вже на цій великій сцені
нашого форуму А я передаю мікрофон
модератор ці цій в обговоренні це Юлія
Безвершенко генеральний директор
директорату науки інновацій Міністерства
освіти і науки України
дякую вас вітати на сьогоднішній сесії
хочу познайомитися
директор Національного центру
інформаційних технологій у
і протягом форуму обговорювалося питання
створення суспільства знань і ми
говорили в понеділок про те що
Суспільство знань це суспільство
розвиток якого розвиток економіки та
добробуту громадян базується на знаннях
а саме на створені знань поширенні знань
та використання знань на практиці і коли
ми сьогодні говоримо про створення знань
та їх використання безумовно ми говоримо
про людей які це роблять і звичайно коли
ми говоримо про вченого ми розуміємо що
це багато років не простої праці
багатьох людей для того щоб такого
вченого створити де ми можемо знайти
людину яка піде в науку як ми можемо
зацікавити цю людину вчитися для того
щоб стати вченим які є стимули для того
щоб молода людина бачила себе в науці
зокрема і в цій країні Отож сьогодні
говоримо про всі ці етапи почнемо з
Оксана лісового Я думаю що це може
розказати якраз про самий перший етап де
нам знайти тих дітей які з часом стануть
видатними науковцями Доброго дня шановні
колеги дякую пані юліє
власне вчора у нас був
Міжнародний день захисту дітей і в цьому
контексті
рефлексу вчорашнім не ми провели багато
заходів і не тільки ми по всій Україні
відбувались заходи щодо захисту прав
дитини
еее виникає питання чи захищені У нас в
Україні права дитини на творчий розвиток
на розвиток в інтелектуальній сфері
зокрема чи відчувають батьки зручність і
доступність середовищ для
інтелектуального зростання своєї дитини
еее ці середовища о
конкурентноспроможність сьогодні з тим
світом який живе в якому живе дитина а
саме еее тим світом спокус так
індустрією розваг
комп'ютерних ігор соціальних мереж тощо
а А чи спроможні ми утримати увагу
дитини і сформувати в неї бажання
до конструктивної творчої діяльності і
утримати Це бажання аж до того часу поки
вона починає робити вибір професії свої
і обере з чи зможемо ми забезпечити
передумови для того щоб вона обрала
інтелектуальну діяльність в цілому і
вужче саме діяльність науковця А питання
мені здається що ви ні в кого є діти які
стикалися з тим що знайти осередок
наукової освіти не так просто поблизу
від дому не так просто знайти фахівців
які будуть готові займатися з дитиною
тими видами діяльності які в принципі
спрямують дитину в майбутньому в науку а
а середовище які є сьогодні аж далеко не
конкурентно спроможні
у але ми повинні говорити мабуть глибше
всім еее маємо минуле і прагнемо
збудувати певна майбутнє і те минуле
впливає на наше майбутнє так
впливає за умови якщо сьогоднішній день
не
коригує минуле Я говорю про те що
Україна якраз є країною яка пережила
абсолютно унікальні події в своїй
історії
еее ми говоримо про те що Україна
пережила геноцид Еліт і перш за все Еліт
інтелектуальних
ми маємо знищені покоління інтелектуалів
і ми маємо глибокі ментальні травми які
працюють і передаються з покоління в
покоління До сих пір і це вимагає в
стократ більших зусиль
докладання в стократ більших зусиль для
того щоб ці втрати минулого і ці травми
залікувати і компенсувати ці втрати
Сьогодні ми ми і наслідки
у і ці наслідки стосуються кожної
кожного громадянина наслідки отого
минулого тих величезних втрат величезних
Але якщо ми говоримо про наших колег
науковців тут всі присутні крім мене
власне займаються саме наукою я займаюся
освітою не плутати малу академію наук
знову освітня діяльність і Ми займаємося
наукової освітою
еее ми говоримо про те що ви колеги всі
працюєте вже з наслідками з тим що
вижило так з тим що пробилися через
товщину асфальту не сприяння через
рівень величезний не ефективної протидії
тим спокусам які забирають у нас
основний інтелектуальний потенціал явища
з повторюю тезу основні втрати
у майбутнього науковця лежать школі і
починаються так 3 4 клас коли діти
приходять і кажуть мені нецікаво я не
хочу я не буду і переключаються на
технологічні класні абсолютно середовище
які створені для того щоб смоктати їх і
не залишить ніякого шансу на
конструктивну діяльність перетворивши
нашу дитину з творця на споживача А я
говорю про індустрії розваг про
комп'ютерні ігри прості соціальними масу
всього весь світ власне заточений на те
щоб дитину перетворити на споживача в
майбутньому а не на творцям Отже еее
цьому контексті Мала академія наук Що Ми
пробуємо робити Що нам здається
що в А що працює на те щоб сформувати
світогляд у дитини саме світогляд
майбутнього науковця щоб озброїти його
необхідним інструментарієм з яким він би
стартував потім конструктивну діяльність
я спеціально не говорю наука зараз так я
говорю будь-яка конструктивна діяльність
будь-яка творча діяльність нехай він
зробить свій вибір Ми з До речі не
комунікують з дітьми що прийшовши в малу
академію наук Ти станеш виключно
науковцям все Ти зробив свій вибір на
все життя і і наука це це своє ярмо
назавжди ми говоримо про те що ми
озброєного тебе інструментарієм який
зробить тебе успішним
успішним різних сферах Але звичайно ми
Стараємося спрямувати інтерес дитини
саме до Наукової сфери до інноваційної
діяльності національної економіки в тому
числі ми говоримо про те ж може
реалізуватись як інноваційний
підприємець ми говоримо про те що ти
можеш реалізуватись як людина яка
реалізується У проекті в перспективі в
політичній діяльності буде але важливо
що для Успіху тобі потрібен
інструментарії науковці
ааа пів методи пізнання власне а
незнання от що ми даємо дітям контексті
нашої роботи
як виглядає освітні моделі малої
Академії Наук на сьогодні вона будується
на трьох основних цілях
перша педагогічна мета яку ми ставимо
перед собою зацікавити залучити Так вона
називається зацікавити конструктивною
науковою діяльністю наукою впринципі
розкрити феномен
еее сформувати й і передумови для
формування наукового світогляду нас тут
презентація так здається що ми маємо Так
ми сьогодні маємо
відображається відображається Так ми
сьогодні маємо в системі малої Академії
Наук А це е вона виглядає як
національний центр Мала академія наук
який працює під егідою
у Національної академії наук та
Міністерство освіти і територіальні
відділення це заклади асоційовані з нами
Ми центром Юнеско другої категорії
центром наукової освіти єдиний центр
ЮНЕСКО в Україні і наша модель визнана
Юнеско як унікальна модель і модель яка
потребує масштабування і наш досвід
вивчається в інших країнах 90 тисяч
учнів ми маємо в системі малої Академії
Наук саме наших учнів в гуртках і
секціях це позашкільна освіта у нас
учиться 90 тисяч чоловік 6106 тисяч
педагогів працює в системі різноманітних
здебільшого ми залучаємо Стараємося
залучати науковців з вищих навчальних
закладів
академічних науковців тому що скільки
науковець спроможний повноцінно ввести
дитину еее світ науки але на жаль
науковці і і не завжди знаходять час
працювати з дітьми і тому компенсуємо як
можемо але ми дуже вдячні тим тисячам
людей з науки які приділяють свій час
для того щоб працювати
250 тисяч дітей залучені до заходів зі
школярами ну власне Вибачте інші цифри
на екрані але я повернусь до
педагогічних цілей зацікавити залучити
еее а
А що треба зробити для того щоб дитина
цікавилась наукою в своєму ранньому віці
потім в підлітковому не втратила інтерес
і потім зробила свій усвідомлений вибір
професії обравши ВУЗ і свою траєкторію
до яка приведе її до наукової діяльності
інноваційний діяльності Ми створюємо
спеціальні середовища які говорять до
дитини її мовою причому мовою в
залежності від її віку якщо ми говоримо
про цей перший рівень зацікавити
залучити то ми можемо наводити такі
приклади як наш там Музей Науки
нещодавно відкритий за підтримки
Національної академії наук Міністерства
освіти на ВДНХ
еее середовище яка власне формує
передумови для
того самого наукового світогляду дитини
а дуже короткий у нас не так багато часу
так то дуже короткий приклад власне
наприклад берем топ експонат наш з музею
велосипедна квадратних колесах
про те щоб покататися на велику і весело
і жваво але і не про те щоб дитина
розібрались в тих математичних
розрахунках на основі якого розроблена
спеціальна підлога для того щоб
велосипедна квадратних колесах їздив цей
експонат про те щоб дитина усвідомила що
те що здавалось би їй неможливою тобто
їздить на чомусь квадратними колесами Це
точно дуже важко і дуже незручно а то і
неможливо власне може стати можливим за
певних умов
а а умови ці формуються наукою і оце той
злам який відбувається у дітей коли
інтерпретатор на експонатів музею науки
працює з дитиною пояснюючи їй це власне
зіткнення кулю для боулінгу з листом
скла не завжди закінчується тим що воно
розіб'ється і багато інших речей які
лягають в оту світоглядну базу дитини
Музей Науки дитячі наукові студії це та
частина яка спрямована на те щоб
залучити дитину в науки але оці
середовище музеї науки я біг не
переоцінювати колегія говорю зразу Музей
Науки на науку не працюють кінцевому
результаті
і якщо ми просто створюємо музеї науки
діти приходять туди розважаються
науковим експонатами це не дасть
результату науці кінцевому результаті
якщо за цим не стоїть далі системна
вертикаль системної роботи з дітьми
залучення їх до гуртків секцій студій
лабораторії проектної діяльності і ця
цей процес повинен бути На перерві
власне з музею науки Діти заходять на
рівень наших студій лабораторії проектів
різноманітних і це вже рівень наступний
це рівень формування і навчання в ми
навчаємо методом пізнання озброює
початковими
інструментами наукових досліджень еее
формуємо особистість формуємо її вольові
якості формуємо спільноту формуємо
ціннісні орієнтири формуємо
глибоку морально мотивацію до діяльності
усвідомлену морально мотивацію власне
наш випускник від ідеалі повинен чітко
розуміти що він прийшов в лабораторію
скажімо хімічного чи біологічного нашу
не для того щоб поступити в медичний ВУЗ
він прийшов тому що він усвідомив певні
цінності а
наша робота з дітьми в лабораторії
виглядає приблизно так перед тим як
Приступити до практикуму лабораторного
ми говоримо для чого це вам діти от ви
прийшли сюди для чого це вам Я хочу
займатися хімією А нащо тобі це я хочу
вступити у ВУЗ А для чого Ну я в
медичний виступає хочу бути лікарем нащо
тобі це І от ми методами питань виводимо
їх на те що Він визнає що життя людини є
цінність і він за цю цінність готовий на
цю цінність готовий витратити значну
частину АТО і все своє життя власне до
цієї глибокої ціннісної мотивації ми
Стараємося розкрутити клубочок який ааа
і клубочок дій дитини так
наступним рівнем коли ми сформували
особистість формували спільноту
сформували її ціннісні орієнтири
безвідповідально було б залишитися так І
тому ми ще в шкільному віці Стараємося
ми працюємо в основному зі школярами це
наші 99 відсотків нашої аудиторії еее ми
Стараємося створити перший досвід такого
дорослого справжнього успіху базована на
інтелектуальній діяльності Для того щоб
Я хочу всю вести пройдений шлях
починаючи з 10-12 років Того часу коли
дитина прийшла до нас для цього
формується середовище досягнення третьої
цілі реалізувати і ми пропонуємо дітям
реалізацію в трьох сферах
це вже це вже підлітки молоді люди еее
реалізація в трьох сферах перш за все
звичайно наука але альтернативою може
бути інноваційне підприємництво і
соціальна діяльність суспільна
діяльність суспільні проекти в
перспективі з якої може витекти державна
служба або політична діяльність власне
оцей активний інтелектуал мотивований
озброєний інструментарієм ефективної
самореалізації базова них першу чергу на
інструментарій науковому науковця а а
може реалізуватися в трьох сферах і Це
третя мета для цього створюються
відповідні середов в бізнес-інкубатор
для школярів до речі єдиний в Україні
бізнес-інкубатор який має програми для
школярів і наші молоді та мін Новатори
Школярі які генерують якість
технологічні ідеї можуть далі прокачать
свою скіли в сфері уже інноваційного
підприємництва науковий хаб міжнародні
конкурси і змагання на яких ми виграємо
та потенціал колосальними одержали в
минулому році 116 Перемоги на
міжнародних проектах конкурсах або
проект Агенти змін для реалізації
спільних проектів це те середовище в
якому ми працюємо власне
основні такі блоки нашої діяльності ми
бачимо ви знаєте наші музеї ви знаєте
наше середовище Ми запрошуємо науковців
до співпраці але дуже один важливий
аспект Чому науковцям важко працювати з
дітьми Далеко не всі Це може питання в
мові яку ми використовуємо еее
і ми повинні говорити в будь-якому
середовищі з дітьми якщо хочемо
притягнути їх на бік світла на бік науки
ми повинні говорити їх мовою і наші
соціальні мережі наша майбутня платформа
малої Академії Наук тут відео
незапускається Нажаль я перепрошую вони
говорять мовою дитини мовою підлітка
мовою молодої людини це той базовий
підхід без Якого в нас не буде
комунікацію з старшого покоління і з
молодшим поколінням Дякую дуже І власне
тепер коли ми трішки поговорили про те
як дитячий інтерес до пізнання світу і
правильно ціннісному підтримати у
школяра далі ми підходимо до моменту
коли цей школяр припустімо пішов
все-таки на яку спеціальність
інтелектуальної тому числі науково і
далі стоїть перед вибором стати чи не
стати молодим вченим і звичайно Тут
з'являється зовсім інші ви А крім
ідеалістичних пізнання світу навіть якщо
це було запалений такий інтерес
включається інші мотивації які теж
важливі власне Олеся блащук думаю
зупиниться на тому А чи можна молодим
вченим залишитися в цій країні Так
скажіть будьласка коли ви останній раз
бачили перед собою молодого вченого а з
того самого який зараз стоїть перед
вибором чи займатися йому його предметом
дослідження вчити заробляти гроші собі
на життя натана жить на утримання своєї
сім'ї
і давно бачили на сцені є декілька й
взагалі я бачу обличчя і це дійсно
молоді вчені які мають власне предмет
дослідження заради якого готові
віддавати себе свої сили
витрачати на це що могли витратити на
інше бути молодим вченим нашій країні
за секунду до
А це важко це сказати важко це нічого не
сказати про проблеми з якими стикаємося
про умови в яких ми працюємо про стан в
якому ми знаходимося
говорять говорять говорять не один рік
і неводні спільноті неводні комунікації
ми завжди про це наголошуємо якщо ви
бачите на малюнку бачите хто ж такий той
молодий вчений той малесенький який має
свою мету який має свою ідею і хоче
впровадити з чим стикається порівнянні з
досвідченими вченими
розумінням куди
це крім того що він майбутньому бачить
далекі далекій перспективі але вони для
нього навіть не і він не розуміючи цього
має свою мету має свою ціль Я сьогодні
буду говорити про державну підтримку та
заохочення молодих вчених і я буду
говорити про те що у нас наразі є
проблем Вони є зовнішніми й внутрішніми
вони є щодо тих предметів дослідження
всіх ведуть свої і
у свою діяльність молоді вчені проте є
один з варіантів завдяки яким молоді
вчені що змінюють роблять Я тільки для
себе але для інших молодих вчених і для
української науки Підкажіть будьласка
хто загалі чув про таке поняття рада
молодих вчених
А бачите приємно недаремно працюємо в
нас є велика спільнота перед вами не
тому що вища голова ради молодих вчених
при містять Світанок України а тому що
зі мною тут стоять вся наша велика
велика спільнота молодих вчених які б й
роблять дуже дуже багато завжди того щоб
молоді Вчені не тікали молоді вчені
працювали молоді вчені втілювали свої
мрії
проектів трошки трошки розкажу це їхній
бажання створити для себе і для інших
молодих вчених можливості посприяти один
одному і та розвивати нашу науку
і я не бажаю цього робити
акцентувати увагу і Я дуже сподіваюся що
за результатами цього форуму ви працюймо
механізми ми працюємо інструменти
вирішення цих проблем звісно не буду
унікального рішення і немає унікального
рішень наприклад дайте гроші Все буде
добре Ні ні
З цим треба працювати треба створювати
програми тебе ви працювати ці механізми
і допомагати
молодим вченим і досі не тільки молоді
вчені мають рухаємось ці проблеми
стосуються всіх вчених фінанси
незабезпеченість соціального житла
нестача інфраструктури статті
святкування матері обмежують мобільність
на зростання не чи не здивую вони є усіх
всі вчені цьому порушується але це не
кінець далі відсутність даних щодо
розробки вчених будь ласка можна мені
назвати топ-10 чинник який минулому році
зробили щось важливе для української
науки а для світу
і навіть будь ласка Чого
немає науки а що ми нічого не робимо
Почекайте виділяємо гроші на
фінансування науки так може є
щось робимо а
а а сьогодні виступали вчені позавчора А
ось і зараз перед вами вчений узагалі
щось чули про мій предмет досліджень
невербальну інформацію кримінальному
провадженні тим що мала говорю не там
говорю нести ми говоримо ж я не кажу що
це вона тільки оточення або держави цей
вона нас молодих вчених нас навчать як
це рухатися де шукати підтримки як
розвиватися в
у комунікація відсутність посередників
Це погане посередники але нам побільше
Посередник який між нами і між державою
між нами між бізнесом та того щоб рухати
здобутки напрацювання вчених відсутність
стимулів для бізнесу щоб вони
підтримували вчених погані інвестиційні
умови вони всюди ніким не настання
компетенція менеджменту в
А це несе в
Ми багато чуємо особливо
соціальним мережам що не так зараз на
усі
А які погані роботи
роботи і є інформація про гарні але вона
десь осідає її не видно порівнянні з тим
що якщо щось відбувається в нас науці ми
цього не відчуваємо ідеться губиться
знаємо
навіть коли останній раз про це чули та
Приморська то зранку да вже бачили
французький дослідниця яка
виявила
плагіат
недостовірні дані дослідження
французьких вчених так А чому ми про
гарне не чуємо не бачимо
невчення менеджери в нас багато є
закладах освіти
менеджери але які теж хочуть займатися
наукою але щось них не це не дуже
виходить і хтось замість них займається
наукою а вони себе дописують що
здивувала в
а й
теоретичне захопленість багато теорія не
дуже багато нам треба впроваджувати
чимось рухати тим же дітям демонструвати
результати теорія це добре але якщо
практична буде не затребуваність не
актуальність нечасті Це не для нас а
у можливості якби не було важко ті
проблеми які описала це не є панацеєю і
не можна сказати що все губимо все
закриваємо нічого не буде нічого немає
ні ми здаємося і є державна підтримка й
заохочення як молодих вчених так і в
нашій країні ми на цьому не зупиняємося
якщо казати про державну підтримку то ви
чули Ми займаємося розповсюдженням
інформаційним опрацюванням і
розповсюдження інформації щодо стипендії
щодо премій щодо конкурсів
у але це цього Теж мала це 30 робіт це
50 робіт Це 100 робіт Максим або з
товчених підтримується порівнянні з
нашою країною кількістю
А це дуже мало Я не кажу що цього
недостатньо але мало і
Я рада молодих вчених всього-навсього
невеличкий колегіальні виборчі дорадчі
органи що утворюється для Забезпечення
захисту прав та інтересів
всього-навсього здавалася одна стаття
Закону України Про наукову діяльність
статті 4 цього Форте скільки ми можемо
Тараса продемонструють дуже коротко
Отже ключове рада молодих вчених при
місце щось на України Взяла на себе і я
дуже рада що ми це змогли спромоглися і
всі ті проекти які ми втілюємо є
результатом нашої діяльності підтримка
інших вчених наш України не тому що ми
от зараз широкими тому ми добре якби
Вчені з наше кредо участок купити не
були виконавцями цих не брали б участь
то всі ці практики ми будемо понад
30nama нічого не вдалося починаємо школи
молодого науковця що це о
а всього-на-всього десятьма обраними
і підготовка їх щоб подальшому замінити
нас ради молодих вчених нижче цей
зв'язок ми підемо А ще залишились і
працювали між собою між молодими вченими
хочете дізнатися який приклад відбору Ці
школи буде сміятися хто найшвидше
Зареєструйте тобто дається 3 години
Фейсбуці оголошення по письмова форма
вони реєструйся то
буде з картин справедливо конкурсу
повинні бути різні нас теж різні
конкурси
є у мене далі після того як ми
навчаємося в школі для всіх будь-який
бажаючий може долучитися до цього
лекторії 20 хвилин то треба працювати 20
хвилин відповідь на питання 20 хвилин
інтерактив У новий формат години 20
нікому вже не цікаві Навіть зараз хтось
вас вже ночує треба змінюватися і
форматами із саме той Це прямий ефір це
прямим питання і будь-хто нашій країні
поза можна
написати просту форму заповнити стати
учасником цього мене історії доповісти
те що він хоче книга відчиненого про сім
опишемо Книги багато Пишу вчених та дав
нас багато монографій підручників
посібників тощо але наша намагається ці
книги донести до вас як презентації Як
свято де можна підписати отримати
власник земля де може цих землях
використати і говорити що сьогодні це
свято твоє результат у мене для книги
сховається навпаки треба його
використовувати
у промовця добу вчених хто займається
крім самих молодих вчених
і ніхто якщо вони навіть займатися не
буде в
у монографії награнд колись чули про цей
проект
Я дуже коротко Отже 12 спеціальності
подається заявка і за рахунок
видавництва видають монографії
нічого такого немає
це сили яких молодого вченого немає а
видавництво берете на себе і робить і на
цей рік ми вже маємо 7 монографій які
будуть видані також видавництва наша
українська наука поповниться ніч
молодіжне науки там де ми робимо все що
робиться вночі демонструємо те що ми
наробили за певний проміжок часу ми
демонструємо ті здобутки які маємо і те
що нам й демонструвати
молодих ще не року в у топ-новина 100
ми зможемо на вересень 2021 року назвати
стоп 100 молодих вчених року зараз йде
оголошення і можна подавати документи і
бути номіновані на одну з цих номінацій
100 номінації ми можемо заявити хто це
такий
спеціальністю вони йдуть за в з тими
сферами діяльності які користуються
попитом Які найбільш важливі я зможу
назвати топ-100
там різні умови конкурс оголошений
адвокація правильно вчинив би сьогодні
група юристів які працюють але
використано прямий метод що це означає
пом'якшений ма ніколи не вимагаємо ми
завжди консультує роз'яснює знаходимо
вихід регіональні зустрічі та обстріляли
зустрічі
Дякуємо
дуже рада що мала можливість і
продемонструвала окрему частину
діяльності ради молодих вчених при
Міністерстві освіти України дякую
дякую власне розуміємо проблему розумію
діяльність яку проводять молоді і дійсно
в понеділок про це говорили що найбільш
активними діячами на захист науки в
суспільстві й самі в А так само із
молодими вченими Очевидно вони є
найбільш активними але тенденція до
скорочення молодих вчених яка в Україні
набула драматичної взагалі
обсягу і взагалі скорочення кількості
і окремі спеціальності
наприклад систем наука технології
математика і більш глобально молоді де в
індустрію іде вийти іде вища зарплата
власного
інтелекту ємні галузі але й акції
тенденцію можна боротися І наприклад
нова організація яку ми маємо в нашій
країні а саме національний фонд
досліджень який провадить грантових
фінансування чи є відповіддю нас на
питання як не дискримінують чи інших
категорій вчених тому що завжди можна
скотитися вид в результаті забути про
якість вченого а говорити
підтримати тих хто якби очевидно має
трішки менший обсяг стартових
можливостей як цього питання як цей
баланс знаходить національний фонд
досліджень будь ласка пане Сергію буде
цікаво й
А я би розглянув це питання більше року
не лише конкретна що робить національний
фонд досліджень А що взагалі треба
робити яку роль в цій роботі займає
національний фонд досліджень
чому молоді дівчини не йдуть в ногу якщо
намагатися виділити головні причини
головні причини таких причин буде дві
перше це на достатньо високий Престиж
науки які безпосередньо пов'язаної із
заробітною платою із фінансуванням науки
а друге це штучні перепони які
створюються в державі в роботі науковці
на будемо намагатися більш детально про
це розказати на деяких прикладах я
покажу що я маю про що я думаю в
по-перше практично фінансування науки
тут я хочу відійти в сторону дещо
сьогодні багато говорили про те що треба
приділяти більшу увагу прикладним
дослідженням прикладні дослідження це
дуже важливо але якщо дивитися лише на
прикладні дослідження то треба віддавати
звіт в тому що
якщо прикладне дослідження забавляє
якась компанія я бо якесь промислового
підприємства ТОВ досліджувалася буде
саме те що потрібно ці компанії або цієї
цьому підприємств отого якщо робити це
площина прикладних дослідженнях то
можливо фундаментальна наука вона в буде
у занедбаному стані Ну так як
відбувається в деяких країнах світу не
буду говорити
на буду буду вказувати пальцем а у
приклад два роки тому почалася епідемія
вірусу в тому передбачити що буде таке
епідемія два з половиною років тому це
було якраз фото розкішний прогнози які
сценарії які
були десь десь фантастиці але воно
прийшла і виявилося що в Україні
недостатня кількість спеціалістів Які
взагалі розуміють про що йде мова якщо
взагалі розуміють як працює вакцина як
працює вірус ще треба зробити щоб
зробити вакцину такі спеціалісти й вони
дуже високого класу але їх мало
як можна підтримати кількість
спеціалістів з певною питання в країні
для того щоб Україна була готовою для
майбутніх викликів лише підтримує
фундаментальна наука це не лише пошук
нового знання яке колись майбутньому
втілитися в якусь інновацію або в якусь
розробив але цей підтримка наукової
школи це підтримка тих людей які взагалі
розуміють про що йде мова які певний час
зможуть стати на захист від якоїсь к з
паперу не повернемося до фінансування
науки
багато проблем про які говорить
наприклад проблеми з житлом проблема з
тим що
постачає обладнання
принципи зводиться до проблеми
фінансування Подивіться коли ми говоримо
наприклад про які сферу Там ніколи не
встає питання що немає житла для
компьютерщики для програмістів Чому Тому
вони тому що вони дуже високі зарплати
Як правило це дуже добре бо тоді вони
можуть придбати собі житло або взяти
житло в найм й інші проблеми
забезпечення житлом які спеціалісти І
взагалі немає теж саме має бути і в
науці тобто зарплат заробітна плата
дохідного все має бути достатньо високій
От і тоді проблема службового життя
житла придбання житла там щось
побудована відпаде сама собою А як це
зробити треба треба для цього треба
звичайно збільшувати фінансування науки
але треба зробити це так щоб ці кошти
витрачалися на більш ефективні й
найбільш ефективний спосіб ця конкурс на
фінансування
отримає той хто має найкраще зробив так
той хто напише найкраще науковий проект
на думку незалежних експертів впринципі
оце та задачі яку вирішує національних
фантастично цього року минулого року
було проведено два конкурси перший
конкурс було спрямовано на подолання
наслідків епідемії але більш широкому
сенсі ми чому в більш широкому тому що
коли в цій наукові дослідження
закінчиться епідемії закінчиться ми
маємо бути готовими для майбутніх виплат
Івана спрямовувати ці фундаментальні
дослідження саме на Кевін 19 та може
бути мені 25/27 и тд
а а другий конкурс це конкурс який
називався конкурс для молодих і
провідних вчених лише в назві можна
побачити що дуже велику увагу
приділялося підтримці молодих вчених
умовам конкурсу половина команди
щонайменше половина команди мала
складатися з молодих вчених Я думаю це
справедливо тому що Вчені з досвідом
вони вже показали що вони щось може
зробити і вже зрозуміло кому можна
давати кошти кошти хто здатен що зробити
а якщо людина не вижила там до якогось в
яку в науці я не добро прийде нерівність
на правій руці та на має достатню
кількість статей раніше давати їм кошти
що вона зробить А що та молодих
науковців тут це незрозуміло Тому треба
включати в такі команди велика кількість
молодих науковців у сподіванні що
можливо половина можлива третина з них
вони дійсно зможуть реалізувати себе в
науці після цього о пане Сергію Мені
трішки дуже дуже дуже дуже
важлива питання отаке фінансування воно
має бути стабільною якщо це брат на два
роки то людина може почувати себе
впевнено ці два роки але цього
недостатньо до вже в залишити молодь
знову Це ця вся система має працювати 5
років 6 років після цього молоді
науковці вони переконаються що так вони
зможуть дійсно організувати стануться
буде стабільно це на буде якась
епізодична розкажем прибуток народ і що
дуже короткої хотів би сказати
про перешкоди Які створюють які є
державі вони вони існували завжди от які
треба було подолати для того щоб
залишати щоб підвищувати Престиж
наукової праці і спрощувати роботу
науковців це дуже Надвірна Дністра та
адміністрування наукової діяльності
наприклад фінансові кошториси треба
скласти на рік наперед якщо ви робите
експеримент Як ви можете знати
результати цього експерименту Як ви
можете знати А що ви будете витрачати
кошти через півроку якщо експеримент
буде на вдалий 2 невдалий найбільше вам
фінансувати ці Дослідження які виявилося
але на початку року треба скласти
Фінансовий план на рік наперед і більше
товар а хто цей план складається
науковці тобто замість того щоб
працювати в науці вони займалися
складанням цих фінансових планів другий
приклад контроль за оборотом
наркотичних речовин
у нас в нашій країні підлягає дуже
досить суворому контролі оборот
наприклад сірчаної кислоти скільки
тактичних засобів можна зробити з літр
сірчаної кислоти відповідь 0 для того
щоб зробити наркотестер Чаном кислоти
треба компонента компонент б
кислоту Так навіщо контролювати Оксаною
кислоти Якщо без компоненту а все одно
нічого не можна зробити з таким підходом
Якщо ми будемо
намагатися контролювати обліку холодної
зброї то треба забере у
тому що ви можете
інновацій для молодих вчених це важливо
в
і так давайте тут
А ну по-перше я хочу подякувати всім тут
присутніми сказати що це дійсно знакова
подія тому що держава звернула увагу на
самому вищому рівні в основі нашого
президента на те що в нас існує проблема
з наукою освіти еее ми тут вже третій
день Я відчуваю якесь піднесення але я
теж науковець тому я критично відношусь
до всього і пропоную вам трошки сучасної
доповіді зняти Рожеві окуляри і
так ми з вами дуже багато говорили
сьогодні вчора інновацій інновацій
інновацій інновації Ну ми повинні
розуміти що багато людей не розуміють що
такі новації що є такі поняття як
наукове відкриття винахід інновація вони
всі мають якесь відношення до
науково-технічного прогресу процесу але
це дуже різні поняття Йому цікаво вони
можуть відкрити і зрозуміти що це за
поняття але ми повинні розуміти що
інновація це вже вправ у когось
кінцевого товару чи сервісу
інфраструктура Наукова якщо повезе
молодому вченому він може тільки
розраховувати наукове відкриття І от
давайте подивимось скільки коштує
інновація
Для прикладу в Давайте ми з вами роз
дивимося яким чином створюються нові
лікарські засоби зараз якраз це
популярном одна пандемія кого від у І що
це за процес це процес від наукового
відкриття який знаходиться на початку до
впровадження лікарського засобу в аптеці
він займає від 12 до 15 років і на
сьогоднішній день бюджет розробки нового
лікарського засобу вже давно перевищив 2
млрд доларів США і крім того в
фармацевтиці є таке правило і русло
інформацію тільки алергії слід кожні
дев'ять років кошторис на розробку
нового лікарського засобу в у
збільшується вдвічі тому Зараз нікого не
лякає
фармацевтичної індустрії бюджети на
розробку лікарських засобів 5 млрд
доларів вакцини зараз вже далеко-далеко
за десять мільярдів долларів і Отже яким
чином все це працює
дивіться на сьогоднішній момент є
синергізм між академічними установами
між контактними дослідницькими
організаціями
індустрією виключно індустрія вона
спілкується споживачем продукції
споживач передає індустрії гроші
індустрія передає гроші академічними
установами і контрактним дослідницькими
організаціями контракти дослідницькі
організації в свою чергу вони
співпрацюють з індустрії
кому цікаво можете прочитати це дуже
гарний огляд мого колегії друга філе
барана із університету сан-дієго escript
університету там описано Це картина
зараз весь світ Працює таким чином ви
можете побачити що в світі існує багато
такі у дослідницьких контрактних
дослідницьких організацій в Китаї гігант
величезний
ми знаємо багато університетів Як ви
бачите тут їх емблеми вони так теж
працюють за цією схемою і зараз завдяки
пандемії ми знаємо Джонсон Джонсон
файберлекс Усмішка й нас це якраз є та
індустрії яка вже виробляє кінцевий
продукт який йде до споживача
тобто ця схема працюю світі вже мабуть
останні років 30/40 в А що в нас є в
Україні
а дивіться індустрія це всесвіті ви
бачите 12 професій Якраз для молодих
вчених з яких є бачите біохіміки хімік
інженери хіміки дослідники подивіться в
середньому освіті які в них заробіток
молодого вченого це на питання Чому вони
їдуть від нас
А у нас є те що казав пан милом
зневірені удавання токсичних знецінення
в
А є така картина але не все так погано
тому що в Україні все ж таки є деякі
приклади success Story про який я хочу
вам розповісти
Київський університет інститут
органічної хімії моїх альма-матер я
закінчив ліцей при Київському
університеті отримав звання магістра
потім звання кандидата і Доктора наук Я
вже отримання органічної хімії але весь
цей час я співпрацював з компанії на
міни яка була створена професором
Андрієм тому що зараз професор
Львівського університету а починав він
це робити на базі інституту органічної
хімії якщо в не Андрій Олексійович тому
що якими моїм науковим вчителем як
молодим вченим всій країні не працював
вже б давно це я вам кажу chest і Ця
компанія була створена в 91 році цьому
році ми
ми працюємо своє 30-річчя потім була
створена ще Більша компанія усі це зараз
працює група компаній потім біологічна
компанія яка була створена в 2011 році
на даний момент в цій сім'ї компанії
працює одна 1596 P робітників вона
стосується 312 студентів працює 151
кандидат наук працює 14 докторів
середній вік співробітників цієї
компанії 35 років якраз там де може
працювати молодий вчений за ці роки
важкої праці я хочу сказати на вдалось
побудувати інтерфейс взаємовідносин цієї
компанії з інституту органічної хімії
біоорганічної хімії Київським
національним університетом харківським
національним університетом але все ж
таки цього недостатньо для того щоб
можна було казати що нас країні є
замкнений цикл інновацій тому що якщо ми
подивимося нашу фармацевтичну отросли
нехай Мої колеги меня мене А в нас нема
замкнутого циклу інноваційної розробки
нових лікарських засобів але досить
недавно з'явилася ще один хай-тек гігант
в Україні це компанія біофарма вона була
заснована в
1896 році майже не чого не відбувалися
2012 року поки Костянтин єфименко це мій
друг які є випускником Київського
національного університету економічного
факультету не почав інвестувати в цю
компанію і цю компанію було інвестовано
більше 75 мільйонів долларів і на даний
момент компанія біофарма входить в
топ-10 світових виробників препаратів
крові і Там працюють більше ніж 500
співробітників і в цьому році ми
спланували такі спробувати зімкнути цикл
в у замкнутий цикл інвестицій і зараз
йдуть перемовини про створення спільної
біотехнологічної компанії з Біофарм уін
Eminem А про Біофарм вже була створена
компанія В цьому році я теж консультує
компанія пресі яка працює
органоїди ми людини це компанія яка буде
розробляти діагностику еее в ракових
клітин це дуже складний проект це перший
в Україні такий проект який є і ми
почали перемовини з київським
національним університетом щодо
створення спільних програм наукових тому
що ми відчуваємо
жорстку нестачу біологів і Хіміків ми
маємо гроші маємо можливості А якраз
молодих вчених нам вже не вистачає Чому
це так важко Я сподіваюсь що треба буде
десять років ще працювати щоб воно
запрацювало хоча результати есть
компанії на місце 4 індексом впливовості
Україні поступаються лише всі цілі
Академії Наук Київському національному
університеті і Харківському на в
університеті подивіться що таке
індексний це можемо
всі компанії було опубліковано в і так
що вже це починає працювати Це інтерфейс
давайте розберемося скільки коштує
вчений Ми кажемо недофінансування
недофінансування недофінансування
в світовій
економіці вже давно використовують
поняття як прайс FT
це
іншою мовою скільки коштує той чи інший
співробітник давайте подивимося скільки
коштує один хімік Якщо ми візьмемо
пфайзер фаєри один хімік коштує компанії
460 тисяч доларів на рік Wave 525 тисяч
доларів Ну а якщо ми змінюємося
біотехнологічного область де більш
складні процеси більш коштовний
обладнання хімік починає стояти один
мільйон 94 тисячі доларів милі багато
людей мене кажуть це ж індустрія Там все
дорого Там все дорого давайте подивимося
скільки коштує хімік університетах і Я
знайшов дуже добре звіт щодо британських
університетів ви бачите цю картину в
університетах Британії один хімік
обходиться приблизно 200 тисяч фунтів на
рік що то контрактних дослідницьких
організацій звідки вони з'явилися в
контрактних дослідницьких організаціях
дуже жорстка ви не розумієте там жорстка
як армія є оптимізація процесів яка
дозволяє знизити
вартість вченого всіх організацій які є
рушійною силою цього бізнесу це дуже
залежить від регіону де знаходиться
контрактна дослідницька організація
Індія Індія Китай
Східна Європа
бачити різні цифри так Тепер давайте
розуміючи про те що ми знаходимося в
Східній Європі ми розуміємо що мінімум
80 тисяч доларів нам треба вкладати в
кожне робоче місце Хіміка давайте
подивимось більш того ж не треба
вкладати ще більше 147 тисяч доларів на
те щоб модернізувати цю робочі місця і
якщо ми хочемо
існуючі інфраструктури що зробити щоб
працювала нова група з чотирьох людей це
1600000 доларів для першого року що ми
маємо В нашому інституті в
а я думаю цифри це коментувати не треба
Якщо ми візьмемо
фінансування яке воно 69 відсотків
фінансування з державного бюджету
контрактів десь 30 відсотків ми все
рівно маємо ціну Хіміка 13000 це всього
16 процентов необхідних для нормального
фінансування
інституту не вийшов не було всіх
здобутків не було би мене тут ще раз
якщо б не було б компанії не мін яка
складає вони тут не грошима а
обладнанням і реактивами доступом до
свого обладнання програмного
забезпечення доступом до бази даних
ремонтними роботами і так далі І так
далі І так далі І все дає можливість
працювати інституту крім того
біоорганічної хімії органічної хімії не
міг вони знаходять за через дорогу ми на
одне запитання президентські
університетськими 2 мільярди гривень у
нас чином вистачить нащо перше запитання
друге запитання якщо ми хочемо ефективне
університет Де студенти можуть працювати
це саме більший парк в Східній Європі
найновітніших обладнання чого він має
бути на виставці цей університет має
бути через дорогу щоб студенти могли
переходити через дорогу і мати доступ до
обладнання і взагалі я хочу сказати ми
тут казали про фармацевтики про
фармацевту Подивіться будь ласка на ці
цифри все лідери
серед компаній які вкладають про син
девелопмент і складають в Індії і тут
бачити не тільки фармацевтичних компаній
ми бачимо Volkswagen не бачимо Google
всі ці компанії Вони працюють
контрактним дослідницькими організаціями
тож я хочу зробити з мосту певний
висновок в Україні при бюджеті в
державному Давайте ми його подивимося
нема можливості в найближчі 10-15 років
казати Що ми будемо будувати будівництва
іще зробимо тіпа Volkswagen очі файл з
Росією у нас єдиний шлях на базі
інститутів що залишилось університетів
будувати контрактний дослідницькі
організації А всі конкретні дослідницькі
організації мають дві долі вони повинні
зростати і при зростанні чи їх поглинає
більший гравець ринку це вже добре Це
буде залученні іноземного Великого
капіталу 6 часом це контрактну
дослідницька організація такі
перетворюються в індустрію Так що це мої
думки які були на сьогодні дуже дякую
Вам довго іще одна історія успіху
сьогодні від Андрія будь ласка в
не
Дозвольте вам запропонувати погляд
серцево-судинного
науковця на стан нашої науки на власному
практичному досвіді що можна презентація
в мене буде підхід з двох точок зору
перший погляд буде з точки зору
практичної класичні фундаментальної
науки наприклад прикладі
IPS стовбурових клітин і другий приклад
більш практичним це стартапи і за основу
взято два моїх стартапи rnet Just save
Life Отож почнемо з першого підходу
фундаментальної науки на прикладі ІР
стовбурових клітин тобто індукованих
стовбурових клітин Якщо коротко Це
технологія яка дозволяє з соматичних
клітин наприклад клітини шкіри або
клітини сечі отримати індуковані
стовбурові клітини з яких надалі можна
отримати і диференціювати їх до
будь-якої іншої клітини наприклад к а й
світів клітин серця і так далі
році було отримано Нобелівську премію
двома дослідниками ознакою і Герда
відповідно дане дослідження проводилося
в Європі тому що потрібно дороговартісне
обладнання ви співпраці з України
коротко звісно дослідження основних
проходить в підготовці І лише потім ми
працюємо власне в лабораторії з
клітинними культурами банках нашого
дослідження ми працювали з клітинами
сечі пацієнта із цих клітин шляхом
індукції вірусного вектора з генами
стовбурових клітин ми перепрограмувати
клітини во стовбурові індуковані
плюрипотентні і після цього
диференціювати їх до кардіоміоцитів якщо
можна відео це власне демонстрація як з
клітин
вищеназваних будь ласка відео програєте
в у відео 1
у вас на кардіоміоцит які скорочуються А
до цього це були насправді така наука на
грані для мене особисто досі фантастики
звісно в Україні є проблеми з
інфраструктурою з обладнанням і тут
потрібно тісно співпрацювати з
європейськими із закордонними партнерами
другий погляд на науку це ж
А це власне стартапи більш прикладна
наука яка може бути використана сьогодні
і приносити користь вже сьогодні або
завтра на прикладі стартапу з 3D друку
та сканування і доповненої реальності
наприклад це потилична кістка було взято
за основу справжня кістка людини від
сканована отримано 3д модель і потім
розраховано на 3D принтері в надзвичайно
високій якості на моєму столі є ще
кілька прикладів цих кісток кістки
статичні їх ми друкуємо а м'які тканини
або наприклад судини артерії ми
накладаємо завдяки доповнені реальності
це один погляд з отієї розробкою мали
честь представляти України вигравати
саме там сан-франциско в нью-йорку в
Європі це один з підходів більш що теж
вимагає інфраструктури але простіше і
дешевше і інший підхід звідки береться
предмет пошуку це власне На жаль життя
час проведення першого дослідження
поступових у них в Європі В моєї мами
трапився в Україні інсульт Нажаль вона
стала інвалідом першої групи і вкрилася
наскільки великою є проблема з інсультом
ми і недостатність в допомозі і так
з'явився другий проект Just save Life
який має за мету якраз боротьбу з
тягарем інсультів в Україні він
складається з волонтерської частини де
ми пропонуємо симптоми інсульту їхнє
п'ять це інфографіка Я прошу вас
звернути увагу це Прості речі які здатні
врятувати життя мовлення обличчя
запаморочення очі кінцівки це перша
частина промоційна і друга частина
власне Ок ми розпізнали симптоми
інсульту потрібно щонайшвидше направити
пацієнта до лікарні але до правильної
лікарні профільна інсультний лікарні і
саме на це налаштована наша друга
частина застилає факту це Foursquare
чому Foursquare тому що в нас є за 190
однієї плюс лікарні які можуть надавати
допомогу при інсульті з останніми
європейськими лише профілі інсульті
лікарні здатні лікувати пацієнтів з
інсультом звичайні неврології і після
цього Чому ми вважаємо яку брати в нас
немає своїх швидких немає лікарні але ми
допомагаємо на основі скарг пацієнта
підібрати правильне лікування і
найближчу лікарню зокрема Так це
виглядає мокап рішення доведеться
симптоми пацієнта вводяться його супутня
патологія препарати які він приймає яке
лікування показане цьому пацієнти Чи це
тромболізис Чи це або це базове
лікування Ось так виглядає зараз
працююча модель із Звісно що проходить
тестування в лікарнях якщо можна відео
три коротко о
I just save Life який допомагає знайти
необхідну лікарню для пацієнтів з
підозрою на інсульт натискаємо розпочати
обираємо профіль лікарні і наприклад
будемо шукати за геолокації ми з вами
зараз знаходимося в парковому відповідно
відправляємо наше розташування
і ось найближча лікарня Олександрівська
клінічна лікарня також можна обирати за
вибором області міста і найближчі
лікарні наприклад Вінницька лікарня
Профі цій лікарні інсультний номер
телефону за яким можна телефонувати
черговому лікарю в режимі 24/7 послуги
які надаються лікарня в них наявний
також вони здатні проводити тромболізис
і ми можемо будувати маршрут через
Google Мапс натискаємо на посилання в
профілі цієї лікарні і будуємо маршрут
до цієї лікарні також цей має інформацію
про і доп на профілактику симптоми і
методи лікування інсульту своїй доповіді
я хотів продемонструвати два погляди на
науку більш класичну науку і більш
Прикладного Startup науку в мене як
молодого науковця є надзвичайне
зацікавлення в роботі на благо нашої
країни я хочу розвиватися тут в Україні
надзвичайно великі позитивні схили в
останній час зокрема це фонд стартапів
фонд досліджень тому я хотів би
наголосити наука це драйвер економіки
будь ласка Зверніть увагу на науку і
прості речі і наука власне задній
рятувати життя дякую
дякую
останньому на сьогодні Олександру
Волкову голові ради молодих вчених
Національної академії наук України для
того щоб ви підвели останню балансуючи
риску під тим все-таки як молодим вченим
в країні знайти своє місце і майбутнє в
дякую пані Юлія дійсно
питання залучення наукової молоді до
питання залучення молоді до науки воно
дуже складний це хоч це болюче питання
для нашої держави дуже добре що існують
такі форми і дуже добре що саме нас
науково молодь питають А чому ж ми не
йдемо до науки бо можливо саме ми можемо
надати правильну відповідь на це питання
перш ніж зрозуміти чому така проблема
існує Я хочу нас хвилинку зазирнути у
тут сферу де я працюю вже десять років
до світу Національної академії наук
України
10 років тому
ми пережили три дуже важливі виклики
національній Світовий і власний
національний виклик розпочався в 2013
році коли розпочалась а російська
агресія
коли розпочалася війна тоді Національна
академія наук України утворила власну
програму оборонних досліджень і це
програма яка має вже десятки прийнятих
на озброєння зразків техніки це програма
де ми плідно співпрацюємо з
міністерством оборони з генеральним
штабом із державним концерном
Укроборонпром це був перший виклик
другий виклик світовий це світова
пандемія коронавірус І в цей час також
наукові інститути Академії Наук
згуртувалися консолідуватися і
об'єдналися для того щоб боротися з цією
світовою проблемою і здобутки
Національної академії наук України у
цьому напрямку чудово відомі і 3 виклик
власний це вперше за 50 років обрання
нового очільника Національної академії
наук України консолідовані демократичне
обрання і це людина яка розуміє
найголовніше це як можна поєднати
існуючі добрі гарні традиції з
необхідністю реформування та у
відповідності сучасним світовим
викликами і
А я можу стверджувати що мінімальна
заробітня плата при якій молодь буде йти
до Національна академія наук України
буде працювати в цій галузі це 20 25
тисяч нормальна заробітна плата це 30 40
тисяч гривень на місяць це була перша
теза друга теза дуже цікава робоче місце
одне діло якщо ми маємо стілець якому 40
років стіл якому 50 років комп'ютер
якому 20 років і принтер який вже не
працює 10 років але інша справа коли в
нас гарний новий сучасний стілець
великий стіл новий потужний гарний
комп'ютер і все інше необхідне
матеріально-технічне забезпечення то
прокинувшись зранку ти захочеш прийти на
таке робоче місце дуже важливо третя
теза це ж і Скажімо так корпоративний
відпочинок особливо це важливо для
наукової молоді це спорт це Культурний
відпочинок це гарний обід Це можливість
відволіктися неможливо займатися наукою
8 годин на день прийшов сів о 9-й ранку
і гості вечора пішов додому Так не можна
займатись наукою необхідний відпочинок
крім того треба пам'ятати що зі своїм
науковим підрозділом ти проводиш більше
часу ніж зі своєю сім'єю а отже треба і
спілкуватися і знаходити інші шляхи для
того щоб порозумітися
ще одна дуже важлива це
взаєморозуміння між поколіннями це дуже
гостра проблема саме для національної
академії наук України є молодь і старше
покоління і не завжди знаходиться ці
шляхи для взаєморозуміння їх треба
шукати коли одні будуть хотіти вчитися а
інші будуть хотіти віддавати свої знання
тоді цей місток буде І тоді все буде
А добре І останнє п'яте за які я б хотів
що звернути Я вважаю це одне з
найголовніших це
баланс між фундаментальними та
прикладними дослідженнями не можна весь
час Тільки сидіти писати формули іноді
будь-яких вчений задатися питанням А
нащо це роблю і коли ти у свій результат
можеш побачити впроваджений у
промисловості потримати його в руках
побачити що їм користуються люди
побачити свій внесок у світову науку це
зовсім інше буде твоє відношення до
твоєї праці тому оцей баланс між
фундаментальними і прикладними
дослідженнями Він має бути обов'язково
обов'язково дотримуватися і.і. А тепер
відповідаючи на питання А чи можна це
все здійснити Так це можна здійснити Для
цього існують інструменти це важко це
складно головне звісно для цього мати
бажання але це можливо я хочу привести
навіть один з прикладів які зі свого
власного досвіду свого життя так сталося
що п'ять років тому я очолив науковий
підрозділ в національній Академії Наук
України тоді цей підрозділ налічував Сім
чоловік з них 5 пенсійного віку якісь
дві фундаментальні теми які тягнулися
десятиріччями Наразі це 27 чоловік 11
проектів і 27 чоловік двадцять двадцять
молоді вчені всі отримують заробітню
плату про яку я вже казав і це проекти
міжнародні гранти це ГОСТ договори з
промисловими підприємствами України
проекти Міністерства освіти і науки
України проекти національного фонду
досліджень із звісно гранти Національної
академії наук України Отже зробити Це
можна Головне бажання і підтримка
держави перш за все у виконанні
прийнятих нею законів дякую дякую
Олександра молодь української науки це
майбутнє української науки а наука це
майбутнє України Отож працюємо наступні
30 років на тим щоб розбудувати нашу
науку Дякую за увагу гарно продовження
дня
Дякуємо учасникам цього І зовсім скоро
Ми продовжуємо обговорювати тему науку
але уже наступні аспекти які пов'язані
із наукою і виробництвом наукою та
економікою на формі України 30 освіта
наука далі в Україні з'явиться
університет який готуватиме фахівців з
кібербезпеки
ініціатива належить президенту
Володимиру зеленському
планується що до університету
відбиратимуть найліпших вступників які
отримуватимуть
стипендію у новому університеті будуть
сучасні лабораторії і біохімічні і
студенти і відразу матимуть і теорію і
практику також очікується Що в
університеті працюватимуть найліпше
викладачі як українські так і запрошені
іноземці
більшість учнів українських шкіл торік
перейшли на дистанційне навчання через
19 за підтримки Міністерства освіти і
науки та Міністерства цифрової
трансформації запрацювало платформа
всеукраїнська школа онлайн вона
розрахована на учнів 5-11 класів тепер
на цій платформі понад півтори тисячі
років і понад 167 тисяч користувачів
125 тисяч учнів 34 тисячі вчителів і
більше ніж 8000 в
на
наш форум триває й знову ми його
кулуарах в холі де у нас традиційна і
оскільки ці дні це дні науки і освіти
далі ми дізнаємося якраз напередодні
наступній сесії яка присвячена тому як
університети наукові заклади
впроваджують в реальне життя виробництво
свої винаходи і свої розробки
щодо Київського політехнічного інституту
національного технічного університету ми
зараз це бачимо експозиції безпілотники
більш докладному ласка нам розкажіть
чому саме вони представлені як їхні
переваги і де вони вже застосовуються
позиції представлені декілька напрям
наших наукових розробок і один із них як
ви правильно підкреслили це безпілотні
літальні апарати
безпілотний літальний апарат spectator
це одна із впринципі успіх ми гордимося
Це розробка яка поставлена на реально
виробництва на ВАТ Меридіан тобто
спільна розробка ВАТ Меридіан і КПІ КПІ
брали участь і розробці і випускають на
реально на виробництві для військових
потреб
інших
відрізняються за своїм функціоналом і
наскільки розумію це його функція без
військових таємниць Але основне це
зйомка так розслідування
можуть перевозити
переваги його це те що легка установка
їх можна зв'язувати по декілька в єдину
цілу систему Для ведення якихось
спостережень Ну і можна не тільки
військовим Звичайно що із інших цілях
використовувати і
у і надзвичайні ситуації інші
це вже що за такий літальний апарат
експериментальний зразок Який в нас
зараз досліджується від опрацьовується в
університеті це безпілотний літальний
апарат який можливо використовувати як
на бензиновому двигуні так і на
електричну або або залежності від навіть
ситуації можлива зміна не приводу самого
виготовлений він із скловолокна також не
важкий легкий і також його основна
основне призначення це відео
камера може монтуватися і може працювати
виробництва і
[музика]
у роботизований комплекс підвищеної
прохідності так перевага цього
спеціально розроблене і він може долати
перешкоди тобто також якщо якісь
незвичайні ситуації Він рухається
підвіска його Може він по сходах
проходити важливо для наших глядачів що
знову ж таки там де працюють
вибухотехніки або якась токсичних
родовища там де не може там людині
небезпечно
саркофагом Чорнобильську атомну
електростанцію перед впровадженням цього
проекту там теж за допомогою
роботизованих комплексів виходу за
подібні
який зараз продемонструвати як Він
рухається допомогою маніпулятора можна
дистанційно переміщати якісь небезпечні
для людини речовини з
а в нашому наукова новизна підвіска
він може рухатись
працювали поверхні так
далі далі далі
[музика]
локальної позиційної навігаційної
системи
переваги і особливість цієї установці
також експериментальна установка яка
поки виготовлена і розроблена
переваги в тому що досить тривалий
період часу він може знаходитись в одній
точці досить точні координати і
здійснювати також відеозйомку або більше
навіть з такими дослідниками з дослідною
метою Наприклад тепловізор тобто
територія яка в не треба точно визначити
її якісь там характеристики то така
система може це робити точне
позиціювання може довго бути на одному
місці Мене цікавить діалектичний зв'язок
що перше це певне заявка від українських
військових чи ініціатива від науковців
Чи це які зустрічний рух чи можливо самі
ідеї брейншторм миті ви проводити разом
із вашими студентами аспірантами і
науковцями які працюють у лабораторії
яка ця механіка це симбіоз Він не завжди
буде однаковий є проекти які виконуються
на замовлення тобто проходять
замовники бізнес які кажуть що в них і
такі то проблеми і Ми включаємо щось вже
є напрацьований опрацьовуємо і вирішуємо
проблему Є ситуації коли в нас є потужні
наукові школи в КПІ де дослідження
ведуться вже на протязі багатьох років у
і на основі цих досліджень особливо якщо
серед молоді вчені студенти
підключаються створюється якісь нові
ідеї і тоді навпаки Ми шукаємо де їх
можна реалізувати впроваджувати
виготовляти якісь зразки
Зараз ми працюємо над системою
студентських наукових гуртків Де
студенти викладачі і
разом працюють або ну залучаються до
роботи цих гуртків і роботодавці для
того щоб працювати над реальними
задачами які є на ринку також
дослідження що можуть виникати і
реалізовуватись в рамках дуальної
системи освіти яка в нас капою вже також
провадження коли студенти старших курсів
навчаються паралельно на підприємствах
тобто в університеті і на підприємстві
частина занять проходить тоді То ж таки
й симбіоз виробництва і навчанням людина
вже по суті
механізму що діє так вийде а гарантія що
в нас буде на виході якась нова
інноваційна розробка по-різному дякую
дякую Бажаю нових плідних винаходів і
талановитих студентів і застосування уже
в реальному житті
того чим працюєте ви і студенти й
аспіранти
нашого національного технічного
університету Київська Київський
політехнічний інститут зовсім скоро буде
наступна сесія яка присвячена питанням
про що ми зараз говорили як наукові
відкриття впроваджуються в життя і як
наука має ставати ну нерозривної від
реальної економіки реального виробництва
про серце зовсім скоро на основній сцені
форуму Україна 30 освіта і наука в
о.в.
А це всеукраїнський форум Україна 30
освіта і наука наступна сесія присвячена
тому як наука наукові дослідження
відкриття впроваджуються в реальне життя
і наскільки підприємства економіка усім
зацікавленим процес цей тривалий шлях
від тиші лабораторій до реального
виробництва поговорити експерти з якими
поспілкується і про модерує цю дискусію
голова комітету з питань стандартів та
економіки вищої освіти національного
агентства і забезпечення якості вищої
освіти Олена Колеснікова
ми фактично завершуємо оформ третій день
і в нас дуже важлива тема ІІІ вона
важлива не тільки тому що нам так
хочеться а тому що дійсно є дуже великі
запит сьогодні у суспільства і о бізнесу
і економіки і у держави на те щоб
виробництва освіта і наука були поєднані
разом ще 10 років тому а буквально коли
ми спілкувалися писали наприклад закон
про вищу освіту або якусь освітня
концепцію суддя не дуже часто нам як
представникам бізнесу заговорили про те
що А освіта це не заради виробництва
освіта це заради чогось іншого але
сьогодні наше панель доказує зовсім інше
наше спікери вам розповідають про такі
кейси які доводять про те що освіта
наука бізнес виробництва це єдина І це
те що створює нашу державу і буде її
створювати успішною тому я з радістю
привітає наших спікерів сьогодні з нами
Микола кизим заступник Міністра перший
заступник міністра освіти і науки в
у
наступний наш спікер Віктор суботін
генеральний директор у турбоатом
компанії
і наступне спікер малого bardot директор
арселорміттал Україна
також з нами Павло директор українського
фонду стартапів залучення до формування
креативної Вибачте
і для мене дуже цікаво я чесно кажу
зранку подивилися багато вашого відео А
це Владислав рибка студент винахідник
вічно блокнот яким користуються
військові які не горить і не тоне
тактичний блокнот і
І лише наукові
Дякую
Добрий день шановні учасники форуму
будь-яка країна світу може мати високий
рівень соціально-економічного розвитку
яке за умови коли відповідний рівень
розвитку освіти науки не оцінні
діяльності Україна за індексом людського
розвитку займає 74 місце серед 183 країн
світу
та обсягу валового внутрішнього продукту
на одного жителя 111 місце серед 185
країн в той же час за індексом рівня
освіти Україна займає 47 місце серед 189
країн світу за рейтингом
науково-технічне активності 39 місце
серед 197 країн і за глобальний
інноваційний індекс м 45 місце серед 131
Таким чином Україна має достатній
освітньо-науковий інноваційний потенціал
реалізується він у
соціально-економічному розвитку України
не повною мірою тому є багато різних
чинників одним із них неузгодженості
ланцюжка міжду освітня науковою
інноваційною діяльністю і реальним
сектором економіки
важливим механізмом який може поєднати
цей ланцюжок є державно-приватне
партнерство в галузі освітньої і науки в
у цей механізм провідних країнах світу
та Україні у багатьох провідних країнах
світу
соціально-економічного розвитку держави
є університету
створює передумови для сталого
соціально-економічного розвитку країни в
тому числі і шляхом державно-приватного
партнерства між державою освітою науки і
бізнесу у світовому в
в освітньому просторі налічується чотири
моделі розвитку університетів тільки
починаючи з моделі університет 3 0
підприємницький і університету 4.0
екосистемний цифровий спрацьовує
механізм державно-приватного партнерства
в якості закордонного прикладу моделі
університет 4
стенфордський університет Сполучених
Штатів Америки в
А який є засновником кремнієвої долини
створив такі видатні компанія Google
і забезпечує цифру вдумайтесь 80
відсотків від валового внутрішнього
продукту Сполучених Штатів Америки
endowment це фонд розвитку університету
становить 27 і 70 мільярдів долларів
стенфордський університет
займає у світових рейтингах і
друге місця
рейтер серед найбільш інноваційних
університеті вони займають перше місце
на сьогоднішній день в Україні немає у
чистому вигляді університеті які
представляли собою модель університет 4
0 але деякі з них наприклад
національний технічний університет
України Київський політехнічний інститут
імені Ігоря Сікорського
просувається шляхом від моделі
університет 3 0 до модельного ситечко у
нуль Київський політехнічний інститут
поступово створює інноваційну систему
сікорські челленджи складовими якої є
міжнародний фестиваль інноваційних
проектів стартапів інноваційний холдинг
науковий парк стартап школа
бізнес-інкубатор всеукраїнська
екосистема в яку входять 14
університетів і 5 наукових кластерів з
різних регіонів України прикладом
може бути національний університет
біоресурсів і природокористування
у складі якого входять науковий Парк 8
науково дослідних університетів три
навчально-наукового інституту чотири
дослідних станцій та навчально-дослідних
господарств 70 наукових лабораторій і 49
навчально-наукових виробничих
лабораторій і також стартап школа Якими
шляхами можна посилити вплив
державно-приватного партнерства в
освітньо-науковий сфері та в інтеграції
з бізнесом в якості деяких заходів у
Міністерстві освіти науки вважають
наступні які втілюються на сьогоднішній
день у верховній раді готується до
другого читання зміни до Закону України
Про наукою партій які передбачають
наступні стимули для учасників
можливість закладами вищої освіти бути
засновником декількох наукових парків
можливість давати на пільгових умовах
площі засновників для реалізації
проектів нової партії будуть
утворюватися яблучним порядком Верховної
Ради готуються до першого читання зміни
до Закону України Про трансфер
технологій які стимулюють і спрощують
процес здійснення трансферу технологій
для вітчизняних розробників і споживачів
Міністерства освіти і науки також
розробляються пропозиції до Закону
України Про державне приватне
партнерство в частині розширення форм
реалізації проектів у сфері
державно-приватного партнерства
і тільки вигляді у договорі як у нас
зараз є створення спеціальних структур у
формі юридичної особи як це
практикується у ряді європейських країн
світу Дякую за увагу
коротко
Скажіть будь ласка мене маленькі
запитання Наскільки Ви вважаєте для
бізнесу взагалі важливо інвестувати
освіту і науку на вашу думку
Морозко університету у них фонд розвитку
становить 27 70 мільярдів Що це значить
це внески
випускників стенфордського університету
фізичних особа або їх кампаній потім ці
кошти починають працювати вже на
університет вони вкладають кошти в
розвиток компанії Startup який біля них
крім того вони фінансують всіх ж коштів
з відсотків які заробляються наукові
дослідження гарвардського університету й
має 40 мільярдів фонд А у нас на жаль
сьогодні законодавство не передбачає
створення такого фонду Я думаю що часом
його створимо це буде також допомагати у
розвитку для того щоб у
та ін бізнесом скажу Вже каже Я так само
хочу угоду тому до вас скоро прийдуть в
і це
Отже Дякую Дуже за те що запросили мене
на цю подію за те що Ви дали мені змогу
поділитися нашими до свідомих і
сподіваннями як ви сказали Наша компанія
компанія завжди зацікавлена піци я
важливій частині
співпраці у вашій країні Тому що тут
йдеться про майбутнє про сталий розвиток
за останній рік звичайно ж
а переносити компанію зелене виробництво
ну принаймні це один з кроків
потрібний
об'єкт але в
[музика]
показати приклад для всіх інших компаній
які вкладають гроші в Україну
[музика]
державним університетом економіки і
технологій
із національним університетом
з ними створили Новий план розвитку
освіти наших майбутніх працівників
працівників
нам потрібно щоб цей бізнес ця робота
з погляду молодих людей з погляду нової
нового покоління тому що коли ми ведемо
мову про металургію про важку
промисловість завжди раді цьому а
там постають проблеми довкілля
компанія компанія у світі щодо
виробництва сталі у нас багато проектів
останні роки і ми хочемо щоб ці зміни
були також відображені в освітньому
процесу
скажімо коли я був в Університеті
навчався у Італію
навчалися
процесів у металургії які були
розроблені 100 або більше років тому і
маю сказати що це частина освіти Вона
просто ну знак для студентів можливо їм
подобається щось інше і
[музика]
А уже знаєте ручної роботи у нас немає
потребує зміни навичок і нашій
галузі
150 мільйонів
людей
дядько м'який в якийсь
важкі речі
впродовж наступних
років
достатньо людей для того щоб почати
працювати на цих об'єктах У нас є
розроблений певний комплекс навичок які
і ми маємо викладати звичайно ми
вважаємо цей проект пілотним проектом це
єдина в нашому портфелі зовсім нещодавно
млрд доларів додаткової інвестицій
модернізації
більш-менш
у нас було достатньо молодих людей які
будуть раді жити в тому місці де
працюють наші об'єкти Отже беремо 300
студентів
спеціальності іноземних мов
знайомитися з Міжнародним досвідом і у
нас дорожче і в Іраку є багато досвіду в
різних країнах
які розвиваються
і скільки це буде коштувати
мільйонів гривень
враховуючи
насправді
мільярди доларів
того щоб вкласти мільйони доларів людей
і ми розглядаємо цих початок здійснення
великої
індустрію але й з водою так і виглядають
вони будуть Так виглядатиме Раду вам це
показуємо навіть побачити що з картинки
воно змінюється це буде новий підхід до
важкої індустрії в майбутньому ми є
провідним у
[музика]
у майбутньому ми маємо робити внесок
освітні установи для того щоб отримати
що нам потрібні
люди потрібні люди мотивовані і люди які
не хочуть їздити своєї країни Україна
повна потенціалу ми тут уже були скажемо
15 років і ми будемо тут
У наступні роки
наступні сто років
86 років власної компанії
ми бачимо нашої компанії як одного із
екологічно дружніх чи компанії у
а для
того щоб показати яким шляхом треба йти
для того щоб Україна була кращою
повинні бути щасливими хотіти жити тут
працювати і впринципі піднімати нашу
економіку і це від вас ще приємніше чути
тому що представниця Металургів і не
дійсно співпрацюємо дуже багатьох
проектах і коли ми говоримо про те що
сьогодні роботодавці не потрібні раби як
прийнято казати дуже часто а потрібні
дійсно освічені технологічні інноваційні
креативні і вас навіть презентація в
заняття була написана розвиток софт
скілс Тобто це дійсно дуже важливі
сьогодні речі саме тому ми одну сторону
завжди Я вам дуже дякую Скажіть мені
будь ласка ти кличеш питання вам щось
заважала для того щоб прийти ми цього чи
навпаки допомагали б
і можливо законодавства можливо
фінансування Можливо щось інше чи просто
поганий настрій
а
Подивіться для того щоби для компанії
такої як ми для того щоб ми працювали в
Україні і
[музика]
А це виконувати закон нормально
задоволення Але ми хочемо побачити як
він буде приємно що в реальному житті
[музика]
фінансові і
у але ми
[музика]
багато патентів розроблених для чого нам
потрібно мати
захист того щоб було розроблено тому що
звичайно
зрозуміти в якому напрямку Ми йдемо і
вони спробують тоді якщо дивитися на цю
цей ви
певні що ці речі будуть вирішені Але як
я сказав Ми хочемо побачити як воно все
буде виконувати з іншого боку якщо ви
ставите це за а
робити такі
для цього потрібно багато зусиль для
того щоби всі зацікавлені сторони йшли в
одному напрямку
багато
і тому все було б
[музика]
у нашого бізнесу тільки Таким чином
можемо Виконати свої програми часто і
дякую
є генеральним директором і стільки років
працює
щось нове Я подивилась До речі я знайшов
перша ваша освіта інженерно-технічна
освіта Потім ви стали економістом Да я
так розумію що потрібно було тобто
кожній людині потрібно рости в напрямку
освітянському не тільки професійним така
ще наукової складової до того щоб бути
успішним і через Повтори з 2007 року в
генеральний директор якщо я не помиляюсь
правильно розкажіть будьласка про ваш
проект наскільки розуміти створення
роторів турбін великої потужності
звучить дуже круто і дуже масштабна Дуже
дякую це одна із наших ти нашого
підприємства але я в А я буду безумовно
вам розкажу про всі здобутки турботами
перш за все хочу сказати що це те що я
буду казати це стало можливим завдяки
тісної співпраці з Академії Наук України
на цьому форумі присутні президент
Академії Наук України Загородній
Анатолій глібович я хочу подякувати його
лиці
науковцям держави які
Яке роблять це можливо щоби наша
машинобудування наша промисловість
українська була на рівні світових
можливості і задач Тому перш за все хочу
сказати що
турба там це стратегічна підприємства
енергетичної галузі 70 України 75
відсотків цього енергетичного потенціалу
України це наших харківські турбіни на
атомних станціях теплових станціях гідра
електростанціях їжи водний об'єм
поставок нового обладнання у та
модернізації на діючим обладнані Це
більше ніж три мільярди гривень у нас в
Україні
А ну хочу почати наші нашу співпрацю з
науковцями безумовно заданої тематики
оце Хмельницька атомна електростанція
жовтим цвітом все те що буде будуватись
перше два блоки це блоки силових машин
пітерські поставки але ми почали
імпортозаміщення
невже вже більше 10 років тому і ми
сьогодні повністю зробили парна
заміщення нащо генерації яка була
поставлена в Україну не українськими
містами Тож ми повністю
еее сьогодні українська енергетика не
залежить від інших постачальників це
тільки ми українці і до 30-го року це
хати Це картина яку ми подарували
чотири роки тому НАК енергоатому з
пропозицій що будуються там уроці ви
бачите була Всі була добудована тішити у
блоки атомних ми розраховувати що
найближчим часом держава приймає рішення
про президента б там же сказав що був
щоб ближайшим часом буде прийняли читай
добудована третя четверта
мільйонів на Хмельницькій АЕС
А це марсал
електростанції турбіна з генератором
1000d роутер парової турбіни 1000 МБ
нашого українського проекту і які 6
блоків працюють на Запорізькій атомній
станції такої ротара на
цю турбіну він вони виробляються методам
електрозварювання який розробила
Академія Наук України інститут електро
сварку імені Патона в Україні цей
технологію обладают не більше п'яти
країн миру і Україна одна з п'яти країн
більш того це перша розробка яка була
зроблена в мирі і вже іншим розробки
були розроблені з урахуванням
наших на учених можливостей
А це ж цех
складальний цех де ці турбіни
обробляються Іра виготовляються в Я хочу
сказати що в Україні Турбо ведучим
підприємством енергомашинобудування
цеп турбіна це генератор це інше
устаткування які потрібні для
роботи електростанцій та й у нас
унікальне дуже гарна ситуація Када
турбіна
генератор виготовляється в разних
компаніях в усьому світі це єдина
компанія цій інсультом G і таке інше і
президент України прийняв рішення
об'єднати турботам і завод електроважмаш
єдину кампанію з того щоб ми мали дійсно
потужна енерго машинобудівної холдинг
який
дозволить ще більш конкурувати на
міжнародних ринках і ця кампанія буде
зроблена в цьому році нам доручена
цим займатись і це буде українська це
буде компанія українська енергетичні
машини із і виховуємо що вже добудову
Хмельницька і станції тому числі буде
робити наша об'єднана компанія це
конденсатори
турбін
один з елементів турбіни які Також ми
розробили розвиток енерго
імпортозаміщення то я вже казав що ми
повністю обрали иностранного
постачальника і наше енергетики залежить
тільки від українських Машинобудівників
А це дуже важлива деталь це
п'ята ступінь турбіни 1000 МБ
російського розробника
А із титанового сплаву яку ми
спроектували
розробили гнилі лишили у своєму
виробництві зараз постачаємо на
електростанції це дуже важлива деталь
турбіни дуже наука є розробка і це також
наш сумісна наша сумісна розробка З
академії наук України і це наше іменних
цьому наша сила такої співпраці і
у Ісаака ряду вже 19 до встановлена на
турбіни і зараз постачаємо інший
А якщо казати про
економічний ефект кажуть далі на
прикладах
гідроелектростанцій окрім парових турбін
та теплових станцій Ми виготовляємо
гідротурбіна для оце карта Дніпра
Дніпровський каскад гідроелектростанцій
на яких стоп гідроагрегатів
турбіни Харківського турбоатома
генератори Харківському електроважмаш а
і на кожній станції фая безумовно своє
конструкція і своя розробка
конструкторської технічна і наукова і
зараз ми виграли відкритому тендері
еее 5 контрактів нашому 5-6 мільярдів
гривень це тендери проходило нас в
Україні за гроші єбрр ді приймали участь
конкурували з нами європейці китайці
Альто Мандри з Китай у компанії і ми
всіх перемогли тіні тому що в Україні
якось
додаткова підтримували не наша
конструкція і наша ціна риночна ціна і
наші конструкторські здобутки наукові
вони перемогли перш за все
А це
еее Дністровська гідроакумулююча
станція сама велика станція в Європі
проектна потужність
одного гідроагрегат A360 мегават
режимі 420 нас основному режимі такі Які
дари бігати всім заплановано три працює
зараз монтуються 4 гідроагрегат А я ми
так розраховуємо Що до кінця цього року
буде прийняте рішення у добудові це ще
три гідроагрегат це велика загрузка
наших українських підприємств і це також
дуже серйозна Наукова розробка ну це наш
ливарний цех де ми з вух ковшей
заливаємо лопаті турбін усе гідра колесо
Дністровської гаес більше 120
діаметр
Так автовоз неділю перевозили це статор
гідротурбіни і я хочу підкреслити що на
кожному етапі це роутер генерації ротор
генератора
ці
Дністровський гідроагрегатів
економічному ефекті від нашої співпраці
і економіки України
а то на наша розрахунок це більш ніж 100
мільярдів гривень за і окупність яких
досягається за 5-7 років це саме завдяки
співпраці
постачаємо продукцію
продукцію яка кожна з наша розробка
модернізація турбін атомних теплових і
гідроелектростанцій це підвищення КП де
це зменшення расход топлива цей
економічний ефект який здобувають
енергетики спрацює сина споживачі і вся
наша держава в
і так і далі це наша перспектива
централізоване сховище ядерних ходу ми
працюємо над тим до подали проекти
участі нашого підприємства в цьому
проекті і нас повністю підтримали
зарубіжні
постачальники це наша розробка модуля
атомної електростанції
які зараз по миру дуже тісно дуже швидко
строю Так ми також дає масу дає свої
пропозиції це реактор
на станцію хтось Україна виробляє і
постачає турбіни виробляє і постачає
генератори на атомні станції потрібен
реактор реактор Україна не виробляє але
ми зараз Працюємо з Академії Наук
України розробляємо в ля-ля-ля-ля-ля
А про розробляємо производство реакторів
тим більшого Краматорську завод
Енергомаш підстав виробляє обичайки а
нам треба і зварювати
а усе
схематично показано наших співпраці з
академією наук України ми підписували з
президентом Академії Наук нині покійним
патоном присвоением договір співпраці
який ми виконуємо разом Зараз ми як я
вже сказав З академії наук Анатолій Глеб
також домовились оно вам етапі співпраці
за що що я вже доповів і ми розраховуємо
ними тому що і на така співпраця буде
надалі
давати змогу
машинобудування України бути на
передових ролях якщо казати про
підготовку кадрів та
їх
компетенція
інститут
генераторного производства їжа а й
кожного кожного до нас приходять до 20
випускників прийме нації вісімдесятих
проходили дуальна форма обучения вже на
старших курсах також це
також це також
працювати якщо казати про
досягнення і молоді також за останні 10
років вісім премії в області науки і
техніки це наше турбоатома
демонструє на наукові розробки і особа
хочу підкреслити що також п'ять останніх
років
А я була прийняти рішення про гострий
біль в області науки техніки для молоді
так от п'ять останніх років науковці
молодий молоді науковці турботами також
що доставляються
прийомів області науки і техніки для
молоді і це наше перспектива не тільки
науково але
України для того щоб
продовжити який казав Мій колега за 15
років в розвиток технологічна і наукових
розробок турботам
склали 70 мільйонів доларів США в і це
також дало нам змогу
зробити все те що ми вам доповів йому ми
не встановлюємо це дуже масштабні
проекти такі речі масштабні цифри Я
просто не знаю навіть як коментувати але
я дуже радію що ви це робите І я думаю
що за цим майбутнє нашої країни Це точно
я хочу запросити до презентації
Владислава рибка студент винахідник
вічного блокноту ви знаєте я коли
подивилася я перше знаєте що я
зрозуміла що це треба зробити в школі ще
і 1 Я думаю коли я була в школі взагалі
про інше думала про це як ви до цього
дійшли що вас надихнуло Чому ви це
зробили і яким чи що вам допомогло А що
може навпаки
А ну допомагав перш за все підтримка
людей які навколо мене як це сталося
проект Спочатку це був економічний
проект екологічний мене було цих
предметів завдання Зробити проекти я
вирішив Ну і завдання екології було
зробити повсякденне щось екологічним
мене вийшло зробити це вічним тим самим
зробити ще й економічно ефективним тобто
й об'єднав дві характеристики екологія
та економіка у блокноті потім від школи
я пішов на Startup Time зайняв перше
місце а далі вже коли проект більш-менш
почав розвиватися Я був на військовому
полігоні дівічки там я побачив
військовослужбовців які користувалися
блокнота мита в них були певні труднощі
записами Ось і так я зрозумів що можна
зробити щось Ой весна для
військовослужбовців для держави та
адаптувати мій проект під
військовослужбовців
можна почати так
у
блокноти і
блокноти
вони застосовуються з звичайними
крихітними олівцями еее записи вони
багаторазові як я вже казав записи
видаляються гумкою або якщо вже
військовослужбовців польових умовах то
використовують вологий грунт та пісок
на відео ми можемо побачити настільки
нанесення це термохімічне дифузія яку
можете бачити нанесення саме на
сторінках не витирається завдяки чому
блокноти стійкі до хімічних фізичних та
абразивних впливів а а в мене є патент я
запатентував цю розробку патентний пошук
підтвердив що таке рішення не має
аналогів Та це ноу-хау
блокноти працює Digital детокс
і те щоб користуватися олівцем це ти
пиши витираємо в а а
а далі загальні це багаторазове як я вже
казав аквафоб ність блокноти повністю не
бояться води вони можуть користуватися в
будь-яких погодних умовах
еее та
звичайного розміру так наскільки
був спеціально підібраний під
формою військовослужбовців це
універсальний розмір формат А6 відомий
формати і він підходить під кишені
військової форми в
а він очищається писати можна навіть під
водою та записи потім що можна витерти
Але після води записи
рукою стати не можна ж
і так
у
військові зраділи приємно Тому що їм
приємно бачити що люди намагаються
допомогти у їх нелегкій справі Ось та
Так давайте далі а про нанесення
термохімічне дифузія вже казав
приклади використання блокнотів У різних
сферах блокноти вже практично
застосовується
слів можете бачити блокнот виготовлений
на замовлення 26 окремим ні окремої
артилерійської механізованої бригади
еее блокнот командира гармати там є все
що потрібно командиру для ведення вогню
тому що якби людина не вивчали це все
але неможливо вивчити
абсолютно все ж
У новий це блокнот в якому зібрані
аеропорти всі потрібні так шпаргалка
можна сказати там знаки тактичні умовні
і всі рапорти просто так викладені
послідовність їх мається на увазі а саме
у послідовності важливості рапортів
тобто спочатку на медичну евакуацію на
вогневу підтримку і все чітко написано
навіть я невеличкі підказки коли
військовослужбовець передає це засобами
та спеціального зв'язку ось а далі ви
бачите більш туристичний варіант це
версія regular називається цей блокнот
просто містить клітинку зазвичай
користуються туристи та люди які
подорожують та люблять вести записи а
далі а це блокнот найпростіше це блокнот
екіпажу танка
т-64б а активно співпрацюємо з себе ту а
блокнот розроблений еее а з фахівцями як
усі наші блокноти які саме для
військовослужбовців ми відповідально
відноситися до контенту який ми ставимо
блокнот тому що ми його активно Ми
пробуємо тестуємо щоб кожна сторінка
відповідала тому що потрібно Ось і цей
інвентар танка т-64 т-64бв
а а це приклади
аеропортів як я вже казав запит на
медичну евакуацію
з деякими підказками Коли потрібно
сказати Кінець зв'язку що не потрібно
казати але записати потрібно і рейнхард
preparation ми її переклали на
українську мову та адаптували більш під
наших військових це картки вогневої
позиції в
о.в. у склад блокноту Tactical саме
найпопулярніший варіант які
розповсюджуються серед
військовослужбовців
це
еее входять зараз вже нові антиблікові
лінійки про них я детальніше розкажу
далі ааа у версії тактікал є дві лінійки
це лінійка тези НАТО та про Трактор Так
ви можете побачити як лінійки працюють
за фактом антиблік у вони матові але при
прикладанні до
тактичних вони прозорі тд
А це приклад заповнення
практичної картки вогню
можна
використовувати тому що поки що у Ми не
можемо сказати що в нас є абсолютно
готове версія спрею є але це ще
прототипу
потрібно використовувати олівець це
більш практичний і зручний варіант Тим
паче Що вже йде розробка декількох
варіантів олівців зі спеціальними
механізмами тому олівець це най
практичніше що є у кожного
військовослужбовця у кишені а
О так у нас є відгуки від
Генерального штабу наукового центру від
сухопутних військ
є відгуки від
[музика]
від інших навчальних закладів військових
і тобто блокноти вже практично
використовуються і це відгуки можна
також переглянути на нашому сайті тому в
принципі
велика команда команда так
ось Мені допомагають
підрядників які
роблять все чітко
терміни часу визначені ось до цього я
йшов щоб знайти ось наприклад на один
процес в мене може бути приблизно сім
вісім підрядників А це здається що
просто потім вже коли все це так просто
і до цього йшов чотири роки змінював
підрядників не всі гарно себе показували
а деякі показали себе гарно і по цей час
я з ними працює еее іноді навіть
відносилося на серйозного потім коли
знаходиться
знаходив людей які допомагали навіть у
розвитку то помислами повсякчас Працюємо
з
О
так це використання за кордоном морські
котики США збройні сили Іспанії Ну і
наша фотка це збройні сили України Це
практичні використання Це просто фізичне
замовники Ось і відсилають відгуки
позитивні й
а а зліва фотографія це нещодавнє
випробування на фронт це 26 механізована
бригада з якими ми співпрацюємо ви
бачили блокнот командира гармати
справа це наші користувачі викладали у
соцмережі в
з лінійки
казав що розповім це лінійки нові таких
на ринку ще немає Це запатентована
технологія лінійки мають такі
характеристики вони антиблікові і вони
внучки А чому антиблікові антибліковий
тому що у зв'язку з
безплатними літальними апаратами з
розвідкою у наші часи то звичайні
традиційні лінійки вони дуже сильно б
лікують і їх дуже легко помітити дроном
а навпаки наші лінійки вони антиблікові
вони не лікують і ще додається ще
додається гнучкість гнучкість дуже
важливо оскільки під час використання
наприклад у Польовій сонці дуже часто
лінійки традиційні ламаються ми зробили
гнучкими ось також ви можете бачити
ефект з лінійок тобто
прикладання до тактичної карти вона стає
прозорою
далі це лінійки які зараз в нас
анонсовані це GTA на поліпшення з
додаванням знаків про трактор в
у транспортир
gto.ua
США
До якої увійшли тому що в нас дуже
багато було знаків вона спочатку було
три лінійки потім ми об'єднали три
лінійки з найпотрібніших ознаками в одну
Ми залишилися лише найпотрібніших що
може використати військовослужбовець під
час виконання оперативних завдань на
кожній лінійці Ви можете бачити зліва
знизу отвір цей отвір спеціально
призначений для білків всі білки вони
кріпляться на блокноті Для зручності
використання блокноту підіймання його з
карт
Ось і вони кріпляться їх ось наприклад
коли зазвичай військовослужбовець вклада
лінійку на карте АТО ліній не потрібно
якось Вибач щоб її підняти і це зазвичай
пошкоджень
використовувати для зручності
[музика]
наших продуктів в
а-а-а антиблік гнучкість відео ви вже
бачили як працює
Дякую за увагу я його учасником мріє
оборонних підприємств при цьому буду на
виставці зброя та безпека
представлений від Ліги чекаємо на вас
цікавить якими Я цікавлюся Як це зробити
та розвинути свій Я думаю все буде добре
дякую вам дуже за ваш виступи І взагалі
за ваш винахід А у нас ще є Я дуже
цікавий виступ Павла Карташова Я одну
вашу цитати з вашого інтерв'ю наша
стратегіями Та це довести усім що
держава є надійним партнером у
започаткуванні талановитих людей я
правильно сказала Це ваша цитата з
одного з інтерв'ю і для мене якраз дуже
цікаво як саме ви молодь до себе заманює
або щось їм обіцяє те яким чином ви
відмовляєтеся від мова для молоді це так
само важко як треба шви брати найкращого
його запитання знаєте якраз попередні
спікер це яскравий приклад того як
інноваційність креативність вона в один
момент перетворюється з бізнес тобто
молодий хлопець якому що напевно до
науки треба університету перейти певний
шлях він же робить бізнес прямо сьогодні
проводять ті ідеї які в нього є
Якщо говорити про креатив в цілому не то
напевно загальновідомий факт що
наприкінці Минулого року визначила 2021
рік
роком
економіки задля досягнення цілей сталого
розвитку
і тут треба зазначити що якраз креативні
індустрії вони є запорукою розвитку
сфери послуг підприємства в цілому а
також культурного різноманіття в
а насправді креативністю назавжди йде
пліч-о-пліч з цифровізації
діджиталізація ДАІ на сьогоднішній день
Україна Напевно є одна з провідних країн
який деталізацію діджиталізації
відбувається шаленими темпами
наприклад Сьогодні якщо ви читаєте книгу
або слухайте аудіокниги автомобілі якщо
ви дивитесь кіно фільми в кінотеатрі або
маєте підписку на домашній кінотеатр він
не відчуваєте жодної різниці в тому що
завдяки діджиталізації витримати такий
собі послуги але в іншій якості
звичайно пандемія І коли вони
доставили всіх нас в суспільство
замислитись над тим викликам і загрозам
які стоять з одного боку креативні
індустрії
зазнала дуже великих втрат
так наприклад
виконавця артистів і А за попередніми
розрахунками не втратили до 30 відсотків
всьому світу так само сфера
кіноіндустрії втратила близько семи
мільярдів долларів але з іншого боку Це
дало значний поштовх Це дало змогу для
розвитку
різноманітних альтернативних
інструментів цей онлайн платформи для
освіти це перехід багатьох бізнесів в
онлайн І це
насправді є рушійною силою сьогодні тому
що вже напевно ніколи не вернемось той
стан в якому наше суспільство заходились
раніше оскільки онлайн складова вона вже
міцно закріпилися нашому повсякденному
житті в
а адже креативна економіка вона є дуже
потужним економічним сектором
і розвивається завдяки діджиталізації
нещодавно натрапив на дуже цікава
дослідження це американське
дослідницький центр
еее це дослідження присвячена як
покоління з-за
впливає на
продукти і споживчої індустрії в цілому
в не
дозволю собі зачитати тобто висновки
вони були для мене дуже несподівано
адже
дослідження перш за все показує що в
у творчості креатив він впливає не
тільки на кінцевий продукт але також на
керівні посади які впроваджуються в тих
чи інших компаній
Отже ключові даного дослідження це
85 відсотків переконані що бізнес це
більше ніж просто прибуток Тобто це не
тільки про гроші
73 відсотки
переконані що цілі компанії має
збігатися з власними ідеями і вісім
потреб споживачів
у тобто мова йде про те що в
а люди перш за все відмовляється
працювати в компаніях і ніколи не підуть
компанії якщо компанія не повірю який
самі цілі елементарний Мауро казав що
вони повинні бути щасливі
Ми повинні бути дуже привабливим також
83 відсотки вони здійснили переоцінку
речей та економії коштів у зв'язку з
пандемії
a75 відсотків вирі чого покоління
зможуть змінити
світ економіку в майбутньому і Я
впевнений що це саме так
а також цьому дослідженні еее виділені
ключові принципи це стійкість
інклюзивність різноманітність і вони
стали підставою для нових креативних
позиції наприклад адвокат з питань етики
в і причому народ дуже важливий аспект
особливо в нашій країні при цьому на ці
посади активно залучаються і молодь і
навіть діти
наприклад посада директор з питань
сталого розвитку це мова йде про банк
HSBC тобто є директор який займається
питаннями сталого розвитку що напевно
для банківської сфери дещо незвичайне
писання також головний директор з питань
впливу в
і цікаво що цю посаду обійняв принц
Гаррі і приєднався до стартапов в
і ось саме ця посада має забезпечити
вплив через дії
а інша
посада яка мене здивувала це головний
топ-менеджери в А це посада яка створена
спеціально для залучення широкої
аудиторії через відомо соціальну мережу
тікток Та я часто питався своєї дочки
таким же ти хочеш стати в майбутньому та
І деколи це дітей
і
він дуже важко дати відповідь дочка
щоразу сюди тато я вже блогер мене є в
Інстаграмі і Фейсбуці Тік тоці і знайде
така відповідь дивуй тому що діти на
сьогодні розвивається набагато швидшими
темпами ніж це було раніше а
у
якісь сучасні реалії які тенденції
розвитку
креативних індустрій в Україні Тобто
можна зазначити що на сьогодні створений
українських стартапів і це я впевнено
можна сказати що це надійний інструмент
для підтримки фінансової на фінансові
усіх активності це можливих стартапів
тому числі які
опікуються креативних індустрій багато
проектів
[музика]
напрямів які є фоні стартапів
відсотках не скажу але проектів багато
оскільки вони так десятки сотні тисячі
проектів нас вже профінансовані
на сьогоднішній день більше ста проектів
тому
співвідношення яке у таксі роботи до
але це Насправді
такий рух який набирає обертів тобто з
кожним днем все більше більше люди
повірили чи можна піти
звернутись до держави і держава надає
фінансування або іншу допомогу для
реалізації тих чи інших знатних плюс на
сьогодні відбувається дуже багато ні все
Ти в одна з них Це підприємницьке
університет Тобто ми ідем ви
університети я спеціально розроблений
курс академічний викладається Зараз
близько 50 університетів
на останніх курсах студентів навчають як
робити бізнес як правильно чого почати
які елементи необхідно передбачити і
сьогодні скажімо такий курс Він напевно
не дуже цікавий економіст фінансист Але
спечемо якщо це який становити біолог
фізик який уявлення немає про бізнес 100
відсотків і курс він буде нього
перекладним максимальний ефект оскільки
він після проходження нього буде мати
навички розуміння як на Тільки щось
придумати і втілити в життя але зробити
цього гроші тому що насправді фонстар
також це не тільки про інновації про
ідеї це про гроші кожен проект має стати
бізнесом і це бізнес має бути швидко
масштабованість і в Україні
необов'язкові займає оце якраз приклад
цього молодого хлопця це якраз той
приклад то успішного стартапи які може
абсолютно швидку влаштуватися і покрити
весь світ
а також інша складова це я думаю що ці
початися вже багато було сказано про дію
світі це той спеціальної правової режим
для який настрій який дозволить створити
в Україні найбільший хаб
Ну і як вона сьогодні час
від часу цей чотири відсотки Я думаю та
амбітна мета десяти відсотків які
ставить перед собою Міністерство
цифрового трансформацію вона буде
досягнуто дуже швидко найкоротший термін
еее також вже на наступному тижні
відбулись відбудеться міжвідомча
засідання так званої рада з питань
розвитку креативної економіки при
кабінеті Міністрів України де якраз
відбулося установче засідання на якому
будуть визначені Які механізми і перші
кроки які має реалізовувати держава для
підтримки розвитку креативних індустрій
тобто на сьогодні вже зроблено немало
скажімо є культурною фонд і фонд
стартапів багато різних організацій які
під чи інші підтримують креативні
індустрії
А наприклад ж наприкінці Цього тижня ми
надамо ліцензію Міністерства культурною
культури та
інформації для використання нашого
порталу порталу фонду який розроблений
для підтримки та надання грантової
підтримки і всі установи які знаходяться
під парасолькою Міністерство культури
зможуть використовуйте наші початку для
надання якраз підтримки креатином
індустрії цей держкіно і ряд інших
організацій які так чи інакше
надають гранти
що стосується фонду стартапів як я вже
зазначав креативна економіка це один з
наших тобто з 15 якими фінансує ми
приймаємо заявки на постійній основі
Тобто ми не прив'язані скажімо до яких
часових меж і обмежень по кількості
заявників чи по о А скільки по напрям
нас немає тобто дуже важливо щоб це було
інноваційно креативно і щоб це був
бізнес для бізнесу то це не зовсім наш
проект це проектного напевно культурного
фонду ось Ну що сказати про Ми віримо що
є дуже багато українських стартапів які
скоро будуть відомі на весь світ вона
вже відомі в Україні це наприклад
лібраріум art-area роді то акустік
багато інших стартапів тобто багатьом з
них вже надали фінансування дехто очікує
на свій піч це наприклад проект проект
який створює інтерактивну книгу з
елементами театру тіней можна буде буде
буде подивитись на презентацію вже цієї
п'ятниці онлайн але я сподіваюся що це
буде ще один проект нашому портфоліо які
так чи інакше в у буде відомий на
міжнародній арені І взагалі завдяки
таким проектам про Україну дізнається
весь світ це
дуже потрібна в країні більше позитиву
більше гарних новин і бути впевненим в
тому що в нас все добре значить нас це
буде краще тільки тому я вам всім Дякую
за вашу роботу за ваші винахідницькі
скіли за все що ви робите Я думаю що
разом Ми зробимо набагато більше науці і
виробництво бути разом так сказав весь
світ тому я думаю ми будемо повинні буде
попереду всієї планети я вам всім Дякую
наша панель закінчується Дякую всім ще
раз
а а
а й
о.в.